nous accueillons pour notre deuxième
audition de l'après mission de l'après
midi monsieur jean marc jancovici
alors vous êtes expert des sujets
d'énergie climat pendant vous installez
j'en profite pour vous présenter pour
ceux qui ne vous connaîtraient pas vous
êtes associé fondateur du cabinet
carbone 4 cabinets de conseil
spécialisés dans la transition
énergétique
on n'a pas d'admirateurs qui va traduire
votre câble vga
j'espère qu'il va revenir
voilà donc j zay vous êtes fonds associé
fondateur du cabinet carbone 4 cabinets
de conseil spécialisés dans la
transition énergétique et l'adaptation
aux changements climatiques
vous êtes également président fondateur
du groupe d'une inflexion d'un shift
project qui a réfléchi aux conséquences
du changement climatique et la
raréfaction des énergies fossiles
vous enseignez à mines paristech notre
commission denquête a notamment pour
objet l'impact environnemental les
énergies renouvelables de ce point de
vue une interrogation général peut
porter sur le point de savoir entre les
différents types d'énergies
renouvelables quelle énergie il serait
le plus pertinent de privilégier si l'on
retient la décarbonation comme premier
objectif de la transition énergétique
la réponse sera t-elle la même si l'on
donne à la transition énergétique un
objectif de réduction parfois de
suppression du recours à l'énergie
nucléaire
dans cette hypothèse le gaz ne
viendrait-il pas de fête l'énergie de la
transition énergétique
que penser de la politique actuelle
menée depuis dix ans largement fondée
sur les énergies électriques éoliennes
et photovoltaïques
faut-il changer de braquet faut-il qu'il
y ait un shift également dans la
transition énergétique à la française
alors monsieur jancovici
on va vous écoutez pour un exposé
liminaire de 15 minutes je sens que vous
aviez adjoint à cet exposé préliminaire
un très joli powerpoint michel misrata à
la technique
c'est dommage d'avoir une salle aussi
moderne est ce que vous devez brancher
sur forcément
là il ya effectivement de quoi ça
ressemble votre à oui bonjour ben voilà
la technique nous étions perdus sur vous
c'est pour monsieur
c'est dommage d'avoir une si belle salle
voilà et avant de commencer votre
présentation
s'agissant d'une pardon oui s'agissant
d'une commission denquête je vais vous
demander je vais vous êtes un habitué
des commissions d'enquêté très bien bien
conformément aux dispositions de
l'article 6 de l'ordonance du 17
novembre 1958
je vais vous demander de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité donc venu lever la main
droite
allumez le micro pour que plus vous
enregistrer et dire je le jure je le
jure merci monsieur jancovici donc la
parole est à vous pour 15 minutes nous
excusez moi monsieur est ce qu'il ya un
endroit où on peut regarder c'est
forcément ici a alors au prix d'un
torticolis vous l'avez maintenant
derrière vous
magnifique on a tous beaucoup on vous
écoute
il est 16h30 vous avez jusqu'à 16h45
très bien alors je vais planter un peu
le décor sur la question initiale pas
sur la première partie de la question
qui est si on souhaite décarbonés
l'économie ou plus exactement si on
souhaite décarbonés l'énergie donc je
vais vous plantez un tout petit peu le
décor sur la façon dont se présente le
paysage énergétique en france
vous avez ici un premier des diagrammes
très jolie kaléidoscope qui représente
en france ce qu'on appelle la
consommation d'énergie finale alors la
consommation d'énergie finale
peut-être que tous les gens dans cette
salle le savent mais si jamais ces films
et pour ceux qui regarderont il ne sera
peut-être pas c'est l'énergie qui est
payé par un consommateur final et qui
alimente une machine c'est ça l'énergie
finale donc c'est une énergie qui passe
le compteur d'un particulier d'une
industrie d'une administration d'une
association et qui alimente une machine
si cette machine se trouve dans le
secteur industriel c'est dans la colonne
industrie si cette machine se sert à
transporter c'est dans la colonne
transport si cette machine est dans un
bâtiment de travail ou personnelle c'est
un quartier résidentiel
et si la machine et dans les champs ça
s'appelle agriculture et l'échelle est
gradué en milliards de kilowattheures
c'est à dire en térawattheures et
maintenant je vais cercle et ceux qui
dans notre pays et de l'énergie qui
alimente une machine dont la source
primaire sert celles prélevées dans
l'environnement est issu des
combustibles fossiles
voilà ça donne tout ça ce qu'on voit
c'est que le nucléaire qui doit
mobiliser 95 % de l'espace médiatique
sur la question représente une fraction
assez minoritaire de cette énergie
finale donc c'est comme le disent
souvent une partie des gens 95,60 du
débat pour pas du tout 95% de la
situation de départ alors que je suis un
peu taquin j'ai mis en vert clair le
nucléaire et j'ai mis les autres
énergies renouvelables enfin deux autres
énergies bas carbone pardon dont les
renouvelables dans les autres
dans les autres compartiments qui sont
au dessus mais voilà mais pour poser le
paysage de départ ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que l'essentiel de
l'énergie qui alimente une machine en
france l'essentiel des vecteurs qui
alimente des machines sont issus des
énergies fossiles comme dans les autres
pays de l' ocde
la grosse différence que nous avons
c'est que notre électricité est
largement décarbonée
mais notre énergie finale est à peu près
aussi carbonées pas beaucoup moins
décarbonés que celle d'ailleurs la
deuxième chose que je vais vous montrer
est pour moi quelque chose qui explique
pourquoi est ce que une large partie de
l'argent parce que ça vous le savez déjà
à ce stade la commission va dans des
modes qui ne des carbones pas le mix
français alors même qu'on parle de
transition qui concerne le changement
climatique et c'est en lien à mon avis
avec ce que je vous présente maintenant
qui est que quand on demande aux
français si le nucléaire contribue un
peu ou beaucoup aux émissions de gaz à
effet de serre vous avez à peu près 80%
de la population qui vous répondent oui
dont 80 % des français pensent que de
casser un noyau d'uranium en deux
c'était équivalent à oxyder un atome de
carbone
alors évidemment on peut considérer que
c'est une faillite médiatique
par contre pas complètement d accord
avec cette idée on peut enfin voila mais
en tout cas il faut savoir que c'est une
source de confusion importante parce que
du coup ça peut expliquer que pour
d'autres ou de gens si on lutte contre
le changement climatique
il est logique de faire baisser le
nucléaire parce qu'à partir du moment où
on fait baisser nucléaire s'il contribue
au changement climatique bas c'est une
bonne chose pour le climat dont il ya
une situation de départ donc 80 % de vos
électeurs pensent à c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut avoir bien bien présent en
fait ça a tendance à augmenter et c'est
malheureusement plutôt plus développée
chez la fraction de la population qui
par ailleurs est plutôt plus sensibles
aux questions d'environnement c'est à
dire les femmes et les jeunes
ans ensuite ça fait satistiques à ce
stade c'est un fait statistique
ensuite ce que je montre ici c'est la
part du mx élite du mix énergétique
pardon donc pas électrique mais
énergétique qui est constitué des
énergies sans carbone alors là par
contre je raisonne en énergie primaire
donc l'énergie qu'on prélève dans
l'environnement dans les spas 50 ou 60
premiers pays consommateurs
non pardon sur les pays qui ont le 50 ou
60 mx les plus décarbonés de la planète
alors ce que vous voyez c'est que celui
qui arrive en tête est un pays qui est
marginale par sa population beaucoup les
islandais en faxant 300 milles ensuite
vous avez pays des pays qui sont très
richement doté en montagne la norvège la
suède et la suisse est en fait la france
est le premier des pays un peu plat
puisque les montagnes de qui me connaît
pas l'essentiel du relief est le premier
des pays du g20 en termes de
décarbonation de son mix actuelle dit
autrement si on n'avait pas le nucléaire
vous voyez on aurait la petite barre
verte et la petite part bleu et tout la
grosse part orange c'est à dire le
nucléaire ne contribuerait pas à la
décarbonation du mix et donc en ayant
mis comme les allemands des centaines de
milliards éventuellement dans les
éoliennes en ce très paisiblement au
niveau des allemands ou au niveau des
belges ou haut niveau et c'est à dire
dans des pays qui sont plats et donc pas
la possibilité d'avoir énormément de
montagne pour alimenter des barrages ce
qu'on voit également c'est que si on
regarde la part du décarbonés dans le
mix c'est un peu discutable de
considérer que la france est en retard
sur l'allemagne hier année alors vous
voyez plusieurs shows et ses émissions
ont tendance à baisser ce qui soit dit
en passant à faire la part des choses
entre des évolutions qui ne doivent
strictement rien à des décisions de
nature politique et des décisions qui
doivent à l'intelligence de la
législation du pays
et c'est pas si simple que ça de faire
la part des choses ce que vous voyez
également sur ce diagramme c'est que
l'essentiel des émissions de co2 en
france viennent du pétrole puis du gaz
puis du charbon
donc si on a envie de s'attaquer à la
question climat dans le secteur
énergétique dans l'énergie qu'on utilise
nos problèmes s'appelle numéro un le
pétrole numéro 2 le gaz est numéro 3 le
charbon il ne s'appelle pas
n'apparaît pas sur ce drame le nucléaire
et il ne s'appelle pas
l'hydroélectricité si on raisonne
simplement d'un point de vue climat donc
on va s'intéresser au pétrole au gaz et
au charbon le pétrole ou va-t-il et bien
les sens là c'est pareil vous avez une
série longue sur là où va le pétrole
utilisé en france alors ne faites pas
attention à cette discontinuité gris
jaune là que vous avez entre résidentiel
et tertiaire à cet endroit là à mon avis
c'est un artefact statistique c'est à
dire qu'une partie de la consommation a
dû basculer brutalement d'une catégorie
dans l'autre sans qu'on sache trop
pourquoi prenez la somme des deux qui
représente les bâtiments c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant est en fait ce qu'on
voit c'est que au moment des chocs
pétroliers on avait beaucoup de pétrole
dans les bâtiments c'est le chauffage au
fioul une large partie a disparu où il a
été remplacé par du gaz et d'électricité
on avait du pétrole dans les transports
c'est un segment qui a énormément
augmenté enfin on avait du pétrole
dans l'industrie le pétrole dans
l'industrie allait notamment dans les
usages chaleur où là aussi il est
beaucoup pour beaucoup été remplacé par
du gaz voire du charbon ou des
combustibles alors l'agriculture
aujourd'hui consomme à peu près la même
quantité que le tertiaire pas qu'une
résidentielle que tertiaire langue rice
et tertiaire donc bâtiment c résidentiel
et tertiaire donc tertiaire c'est les
locaux professionnels résidentiels c'est
les logements
donc oui l'agriculture est pas
complètement des pétroles ise en fait
l'agriculture a également une énorme
dépendance aval au pétrole
parce qu'en france vous avez entre le
tiers et la moitié des camions qui
transportent des choses qui se mange
donc vous avez une defwin dépenses une
dépendance pas fini ma sieste une
dépendance de l'alimentation des villes
au pétrole qui est absolument massive
si demain matin je supprime le pétrole
overnight les deux tiers des parisiens
meurent de faim du camion puis
d'alimentation des villes
donc vous avez une dépendance
aujourd'hui du pays au pétrole notamment
pour la survie à court terme c'est à
dire manger qui est très très
significative comme dans tous les pays
organisé de l'oscd donc pardon donc ça
veut dire que si on s'intéresse au co2
on s'intéresse d'abord au pétrole et si
on s'intéresse d'abord au pétrole ou
s'intéresse d'abord aux transports c'est
ça que je suis en train de dire avec
ceux avec ses graphiques après la
question est de savoir où va alors par
vous constaté également que la quantité
de pétrole qu'on utilise en france a
commencé à diminuer depuis le début des
années 2000 alors on y reviendra
peut-être s'il ya des questions pour moi
ça ne doit strictement rien à la
politique climat de la france rien et ça
doit tout au fait que la mer du nord a
passé son pic de production en 2000 que
le monde a passé son pic de production
sur le conventionnel en 2008 et que donc
la capacité de la france à importer plus
de pétrole quand bien même elle le
voudrait est extrêmement limité même si
on se fiche du climat de toute façon
l'avenir du pays va s'écrire avec de
moins en moins de pétrole en tendance on
a été un peu ré alimenté ces dernières
années par le boom du shale oil aux
états unis mais ça va pas durer
éternellement
et ça serait aussi un sujet intéressant
ou avoir je sais pas si c'est une
commission denquête ou une mission
d'information mais pour savoir si on a
les idées claires dans ce pays sur
l'approvisionnement pétrolier futur je
pense que ça vaudrait le coup parce que
mon pari sur la réponse est que ces noms
à peu près partout le après nous
utilisons donc du gaz alors le gaz ou
est-ce qu'il va il va d'abord dans les
bâtiments un gros 50 % du gaz qu'on
utilise en france va dans le chauffage
après vous avez une petite un gros tiers
on va dire qui va dans l'industrie et
vous avez 10 15% qui va dans les usages
chaleur
pardon chaleur et électricité dont à peu
près la moitié pour l'électricité
donc si on veut s'intéresser pardon et
puis si on veut s'intéresser au gaz et
au pétrole en france on s'intéresse aux
transports et aux bâtiments
enfin nous utilisons du charbon alors
excusez moi que j'ai pas précisé les
ordonner là dessus les ordonner c'est
des millions de tonnes équivalent
pétrole
la consommation primaire en france est
de 240 avec 7 unités et de mémoire la
finale et aux alentours de 150 160 voilà
donc là vous avez une idée ça fait 80
sur 240 là ça fait quarante sur 240 et
là vous avez 10 sur 240 vous voyez le
charbon c'est pas une grosse source
d'énergie primaire
alors où est le charbon il va dans la
sidérurgie et il va dans l'électricité
est un peu dans l'industrie mais en gros
c'est moitié sidérurgie petite moitié
électricité donc si on s'intéresse au
charbon le grand paradoxe c'est qu'avant
de s'intéresser aux centrales à charbon
vous intéressez vous aux fourneaux donc
si nous sommes dans l'est de la france
il ya une question à se poser c'est est
ce qu'il vaut mieux fermer florange ce
qu'il vaut mieux fermer fessenheim
voilà tant qu'à mettre des gens sur le
carreau peut se poser la question de
savoir quelle est la bonne chose à faire
mais alors nous avons maintenant des
énergies renouvelables en france donc
toujours avec l'unité du million de
tonnes équivalent-pétrole c'est-à-dire
240 pour l'ensemble de la consommation
française
vous avez ici les énergies renouvelables
que nous utilisons en france lorsque
vous voyez c'est que les deux premières
en france comme dans le monde sont le
bois et l'hydroélectricité
donc on a une hiérarchie qui est très
exactement semblable à celle que vous
avez dans la dans le monde dans son
ensemble
et puis ensuite on a tout un tas de
trucs qui sont parfois rapidement
croissant mais qui représente encore
aujourd'hui des choses qui sont en
valeur absolue raisonnablement
raisonnablement marginal vous dans les
choses les moins marginal de l'ensemble
on va dire on a ici le bio diesel alors
le bio diesel est une énergie qui est
partiellement renouvelables puisque vous
retrouver dans la production de bio
diesel des intrants fossiles il ya de
l'énergie de traction des détracteurs
vous avez le gaz qui sert à la
fabrication des engrais azotés pour la
fertilisation et c'est donc vous
retrouver ça donc il faut faire un bilan
en est et si vous avez en plus un
changement d'affectation des terres
c'est à dire qu'on à déforester pour
mettre les cultures qui vont permettre
d'avoir un approvisionnement énergétique
alors le bilan carbone de l'ensemble est
pire que si on utilisait du pétrole pour
qu'on a on a une équation sur les
carburants d'origine agricole qui est
très très dépendante de est ce que on à
valoriser des terres qui servait à rien
par ailleurs où est-ce qu'on a dû
prendre sur la forêt directement ou
indirectement parce que si on prend sur
les cultures alimentaires après les
cultures alimentaires elle mène peuvent
prendre sur la forêt directement ou
indirectement est-ce qu'on a dû prendre
sur des écosystèmes si la réponse oui
oui c'est des biocarburants de première
génération mais même en france on peut
se poser la question qu'est ce qu'on
aurait fait de la terre si on n'avait
pas fait ça si on peut vraiment se poser
la question
on aurait pu développer des puits de
carbone n'aura pu enfin voilà c'est pas
une question qui est complètement idiote
même pour les biocarburants de première
génération
on voit également en eau donc l'éolien a
bien connu et en bas un truc qui est
beaucoup moins connus qui sont les
pompes à chaleur
alors les pompes à chaleur on compte
comme pas renouvelable dans les pompes à
chaleur la chaleur transféré du sol ou
de l'air dans le logement
une pompe à chaleur assez un frigo
inversée donc à frigo vous connaissez le
principe ça refroidit l'intérieur du
frigo et corrélativement ça réchauffe la
cuisine dans leur frigo il fait chaud il
pompe à chaleur c'est un frigo dont la
partie froide et branché sur l'extérieur
donc on refroidit l'extérieur et on
réchauffe l'intérieur et ça s'appelle
pompes à chaleur parce que comme un
frigo c'est un système de transfert de
calories de part et d'autre d'une
paroisse avec un rendement parce que la
thermodynamique permet ça quand pour
transfert des calories on peut utiliser
moins d'énergie pour transférer les
calories que l'énergie qui a dans la
calorie transféré c'est ça l'intérêt
pour ce qui s'appelle une pompe
et il ya même une directive européenne
qui dit que la façon de compter la part
renouvelables des pompes à chaleur c'est
la chaleur transférer - l'électricité
utilisée pour le transfert c'est ça la
façon de les compter donc là ce que vous
avez c'est la part renouvelables c'est à
dire la chaleur transférer -
l'électricité utilisée pour le pour le
transfert donc les pompes à chaleur sont
dans les nerfs c'est un truc intéressant
à savoir est ici vous avez donc l'éolien
et le solaire et vous avez ce que vous
savez aussi à ce stade dont vous voyez
retrouver ici le solaire voyez qu'il est
allé même dans l'ensemble des années en
france raisonnablement marginal et ça ne
l'empêchent pas quand même aujourd'hui
de capter quasiment la moitié du soutien
c'est à dire des impôts des gens qui
nous écoutent pour le développement de
cette forme d'énergie renouvelable
donc effectivement on peut légitimement
se poser la question de savoir si c'est
là qu'on doit mettre entre argent en
premier si le but du jeu c'est de
décarbonée
c'est plus que l'éolien oui le soutien
public en soutien public c'est plus que
l'éolien c'est le cas également en
allemagne
voilà ça ça leur a coûté plus cher que
l'éolien alors il ya quelques après
effets de bord qui sont liées à
l'introduction de l'éolien et du solaire
que je voulais vous présenter vous
rappeler de cette vieille blague de
notre jeunesse qui est ça dépend du sens
du vent et bien en l'occurrence le prix
le prix de marché de l'électricité
maintenant dépend vraiment du sens du
vent ou plus exactement de son intensité
ici vous avez une régression que j'ai
fait sur l'année 2016 avec des données
qui sont dans l'espace public
compilés par un ingénieur danois qui
travaillait justement dans l'intégration
de l'éolien dans le réseau qui met à
disposition des séries des séries
longues et donc là vous avez opa
horaires pour l'allemagne un graphique
qui est fait de la manière suivante
chaque point sur le graphique vous donne
en abscisse la production éolienne pour
l'heure considéré donc c'est un point
par heure en 1760 heures sur l'année un
point d'ailleurs et en ordonnée le prix
de marché d'électricité en allemagne au
même moment est ce que vous montre ce
graphique sans aucune
incertitude erreur d'interprétation
possible c'est que plus la production
éolienne horaire est élevée et plus le
prix de marché au même moment est faible
ça se voit très bien est ce qu'on voit
également c'est qu'on voit apparaître
des prix négatifs au bout d'un d'un
certain temps dit autrement vous avez
actuellement après 50 gigawatts de
puissance installée d'éolien en
allemagne donc quand ça commence à
dépasser 20% de la capacité installée du
autrement quand le facteur de charge
dépasse 20%
vous voyez apparaître des prix négatifs
alors ils sont pas très négatif là au
début mais en fait ils peuvent atteindre
envoyer certains moins 120 il ya une
heure où ça atteint moins 130 euros -
alors c'est quoi un prix négatif
ça veut dire que ça vaut moins cher pour
le système de vous payer pour prendre de
l'électricité dont vous n'avez pas
besoin on vous paye paye le consommateur
plutôt que des branches et de rebrancher
le système c'est ça que ça veut dire
les 20% ces vingt morceaux de la
puissance installée
si on a 20 % de production éolienne
installée
ça veut dire que si vous avez 50
gigawatts de capacités installées si la
puissance effective du parc à ce moment
là dépasse les 10 gigawatts
on commence à avoir un dea en effet de
bord des prix négatifs qui apparaissent
c'est un certain effet alors je vous ai
pas assommer puisque j'avais que 15
minutes pour cet exposé liminaire mais
si je fais des régressions puissance et
au lit afin puissance éolienne horaires
versus prix de marché dans les autres
pays qui ont de l'éolien j'arrive
exactement au même résultat c'est pareil
en espagne c'est pareil etc
alors cette affaire-là est intéressante
parce que ça veut dire que quand il ya
beaucoup de vent et donc beaucoup de
production éolienne à ce moment là les
prix de marché sont bas et donc les
producteurs ne vont pas pouvoir vendre
au prix de marché et quand y aura du
vent pour bien gagner leur vie puisque à
ce moment là le prix de marché et bah
c'est un effet qui a été mis en évidence
par deux économistes récent de deux
mines paristech dans un papier qu'ils
ont publiées fille non et je me rappelle
plus de son comparse où il faisait
remarquer que c'était un effet qui
n'étaient pas pris en compte dans les
modèles 100% vénère qui était qu'on ne
pouvait pas assumer que les producteurs
éolien vendait en permanence leur
électricité aux primes
rien du marché parce que ce que vous
disent graphique c'est que quand il ya
beaucoup de vent ils vendront en fait
leur électricité en dessous du prix
moyen du marché
si le marché s'effondre quand il ya
beaucoup de vent ça veut dire que la
moyenne du prix de marché sur l'année
n'est pas la moyenne du prix de marché
quand il ya du vent
la moyenne du prix de marché quand il ya
du vent est plus basse et donc vous
pouvez pas supposer que ces gens là
doivent vendre au prix de marché moyen
sur l'année
il faut pour que le système marche bien
qu'ils vendent au prix moyen de marché
quand il ya du vent qui est plus bas et
donc si le prix de revient d'un mégawatt
heure éoliens en allemagne et de même 40
ou 50 euros
eh bien vous voyez que 50 euros c'est un
prix de marché qui dès que vous dépassez
les quinze gigawatts de puissance
injecter des vous êtes au delà de ceux
de ce quinze mille là bas vous voyez que
vous n'avez plus jamais un prix qui
dépasse 50
donc si le prix de revient du
mégawattheure éolien et 50 euros ça veut
dire que pour toute cette partie là les
producteurs perdent de l'argent est là
où je veux en venir c'est que du coup
c'est pas du tout sûr que si on a un
prix de marché est un marché organisé
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui on puisse se
passer des subventions
même quand l'éolien sera très
significatif dans le parc installé et en
fait plus les significatif dans le parc
installé plus vous aurez cet effet de
yoyo avec un prix de marché qui déprime
quand ya du vent vous voulez je leur dis
autrement que c'est clair non ça veut
dire en gros que c'est pas du tout sûr
qu'on puisse arrêter les subventions
quand il aura beaucoup d'éolien ya pas
de foisonnement alors je vais dire après
donc là vous et enfin ou plus exactement
il n'a pas suffisamment conçoit que les
10 autres mots ça veut dire que plus on
fait de l'éolien plus on a besoin de
subventions plus vous aurez un nombre
important d'épisodes où vous aurez
beaucoup d'électricité est plus que le
marché ne peut en absorber et à ce
moment les prix sont bas et ça veut dire
que le prix de revient qui nous est
donnée en disant on sort à l'appel
d'offres à 60 euros du kilomètre du
mégawattheure c'est un prix moyen c'est
le prix moyen de rentabilité mais ce
n'est pas un prix
qui correspond à la période où il ya du
vent du vent absolument d'accord
et d'autre part il faut bien comprendre
qu'en fait cet effet là est liée au fait
que les producteurs on ne leur demande
pas de rendre leur kilowattheure
pilotable dit autrement ou leur dis vous
me donnez le kilowattheure quand le vent
souffle épique antilla pas devant vous
mais alors que les centrales classiques
on leur dit vous me donnez le
kilowattheure quand moi j'ai besoin
d'allumer la lumière
pardon oui mais sauf qu'il n'est pas à
la charge des producteurs
donc en fait la bonne manière alors ça
c'est un truc absolument capital la
bonne manière économique de comparer des
sources pilotable et des sources non
pilotable vous n'avez que l'une des deux
options suivantes
ou bien vous dit pour le moment le
réseau s'est développé avec des sources
pilotable et le train de 8 heures par à
8 heures il parle pas quand il ya du
vent et la commission se réunit à 16h15
elle se réunit pas quand il ya du vent
et vos enfants font leurs devoirs le
soir en hiver quand ils ont leurs
devoirs à faire et pas quand il ya du
vent et votre frigo fonctionne au mois
d'août quand il doit fonctionner et pas
quand il ya du vent et vous faites-le
votre lessive le week-end parce que le
en semaine des parfums de pau c est pas
content ya du vent bon alors si c'est
comme ça que s'est construit le système
électrique alors il ya un peu
d'effacement possible mais pas tant que
ça puis en plus une partie c'est pas du
vrai effacement parce que c'est juste
des gens qui mettent des groupes
électrogènes en route donc notamment
chez les industriels du parti de
l'effacement c'est ça
donc ce que donc vous si vous remplacez
une source pilotable par de l'éolien ou
du solaire
si vous voulez garder la même
organisation du système avec pas plus de
coûts à la charge des gens qui
consomment l'électricité ou qui font
fonctionner le réseau
si vous ne demandez pas aux
consommateurs d'investir dans des
batteries et vous ne demandez pas aux
réseaux d'investir venez moyens de
stockage ça veut dire que les gens qui
fournissent de l'électricité non
pilotable ou bien vous leur dites vous
me rajouter les moyens de stockage qui
revend l'électricité pilotable donc
c'est à votre charge de rajouter des
batteries de l'hydrogène au fouquet's
qui exactement ce que vous voulez mais
moi je veux le kilowattheure quand j'en
ai besoin
pas quand et du vent et à ce moment le
haut avec le stockage il est évident
vous sortez pas 60 euros le
mégawattheure beau multiplié par 3,6 en
ordre de grandeur
ou alors vous dites on m'a très bien je
garde mes capacités pilotable en backup
est en fait vous allez voir que c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé en
allemagne donc moi mon pari c'est que si
on développe l'éolien et le solaire en
france on ne baissera pas la puissance
nucléaire de manière significative
on baissera son facteur de charge mais
pas la puissance installée
je vous le montrez après et à ce moment
vous devez comparer le coût complet de
l'éolien et du solaire au coût du
combustible éviter dans le moyen
pilotable dont vous ne vous servez pas
quand il ya du vent ou du soleil répéter
ça très longtemps ce jeu réussit donc on
garde en gros ou garder le moyen
pilotable ce que vous en avez besoin
pour que le train de 8 heures parts à 8
heures le jour il ya pas de morts et pas
de soleil et ça arrive de temps en temps
et à ce moment ce moyen pilotable quand
il ya du vent et du soleil ce que vous
faites si vous ne vous en servez pas
donc vous allez économiser la part
variable de production alors dans une
centrale à gaz la part variable de
production c'est 60% du coût du
kilowattheure vous êtes en gros à 5
entre 50 et 60 euros du mégawattheure
quand gaz dans un mégawatt heure produit
au gaz soit acheter le gaz entre 50 et
60 euros dont 40 et 60 rien à dire dans
une centrale à charbon c'est beaucoup
plus bas dans une centrale nucléaire ça
tangente le zéro c'est à dire que quand
vous vous en servez pas le combustible
que vous économisez dans une centrale
nucléaire c'est allé de l'ordre de
l'euro le mégawattheure à peu près rien
économisez vos arrêts de tranche ça va
pas changer la programmation java jury
parce que c'est programmé pour d'autres
raisons et c'est en fournit un tout
petit peu moins d'uranium éventuellement
au début mais ça va pas jouer sur grand
chose
donc si vous dites je prends le vent et
le soleil quand il ya du vent et du
soleil à ce moment j'arrête mes
centrales nucléaires pour que ça
devienne compétitif le vent et le soleil
il faut à ce moment que ça descende en
dessous de quelques euros le
mégawattheure en france là où vous avez
que du gaz non c'est compétitif à 50
là où vous avez du charbon c'est
compétitif à 20 là où vous avez du
nucléaire ou des barrages c'est
compétitif à zéro plus on va dire c'est
à dire jamais et quand la presse
n'arrête pas de répéter le coût du
l'éolien est inférieur au coût du
nouveau nucléaire elle compare des choux
et des carottes
c'est à dire qu'elle compare une source
pilotable et une source non pilotable et
dans un réseau où par définition
l'électricité de l'électricité c'est un
électron en mouvement donc en tant que
tel ça se stocke pas c'est un stockables
en tant que tel sauf dans les
supraconducteurs mais sinon faut le
transformer en autre chose pour stocker
l'électricité faut le transformer en or
monter en altitude dans les barrages
réversible en composés chimiques dans
une batterie etc
mais en tant que tel ça se stocke pas
l'électricité donc dans un réseau à tout
instant la production et la consommation
s'équilibre et à tout instant la
fréquence est stable c'est ça le but du
jeu de si vous avez des modes de
production qui ne sont pas pilotable
vous ne pouvez les comparer que à du
combustible économiser en ayant gardé
les moyens pilotable c'est tout ce que
vous pouvez faire et donc vous ne vous
pouvez regarder que la part variable qui
est économisé et c'est la raison pour
laquelle soit dit en passant
quand vous rajoutez un système à coût
fixe qui est le nucléaire que vous allez
devoir garder un autre système à coût
fixe qu'elle est au lien il solaire
à l'arrivée la facture globale augmente
et elle augmente à mesure de la quantité
d'éolien et de solaire que vous allez
rajouter dans le système parce qu'il n'y
aura pas substitution il y aura
superposition je vais vous montrer juste
après quand on parle de complémentarité
je les voyais complémentarité cc c'est
une super position
je vais vous montrer juste après ici
vous avez la même chose en allemagne en
j'ai mis cette fois production éolienne
et solaire
les deux dont vous voyez le nuage de
points est également extrêmement
explicite ce que vous voyez c'est que
plus la production éolienne et solaire
horaire est importante et plus le prix
de marché et bas et du reste alpiq l'a
appris à ses dépens en suisse alors
voilà la question du foisonnement non
pardon ça c'est la question des
exportations
ici j'ai fait un deuxième graphique qui
vous donne la production éolienne heure
par heure et les exportations allemandes
heure par heure ce que vous voyez là
aussi sur ce graphique c'est que plus la
production éolienne est élevé et plus
les exportations horaires sont élevés
une autre manière de dire la même chose
c'est que en fait quand le vent souffle
l'allemagne exporte de manière fatale
alors c'est intéressant de garder ça en
tête parce que justement ce que je vais
vous montrer juste après c'est qu' il
n'y a pas de foisonnement au sens où on
l'entend habituellement c'est à dire que
en gros quand il ya une dépression en
europe il ya du vent chez un peu tout le
monde et quand il ya un anticyclone ya
du vent chez pearson et alors ça se
matérialise sur le graphique que je vous
montre maintenant où vous avez heure par
heure le facteur de charge du parc
éolien allemand c'est à dire à quelle
part de sa puissance installée il
produit et pour la même heure le facteur
de charge du parc éolien français c'est
à dire quel est le la puissance réelle
par rapport à la puissance installée est
ce qu'on voit c'est que les moments où
il ya vraiment pas beaucoup de vent en
allemagne donc vous êtes à une faible
fraction du parc la puissance réelle est
une faible fraction de la puissance
installée avec ses piles à ce moment là
qui a pas beaucoup de vent non plus en
france donc l'idée qu'on va pouvoir
compter sur le vent des voisins quand on
en a pas chez nous moi je parierais pas
mon propre argent là dessus donc je veux
bien que les gens qui disent que c'est
possible paris leur propre argent là
dessus bien pour les paris
par contre ce qu'on constate c'est que
au moment où on a beaucoup de vent
il faut que je coupe le mien pardon
ouais ça et ça marche c'est mieux oui il
me semble en fait là en fait faut qu'on
regarde une diagonale
enfin j'avais faut bien comprendre ce
qui représente le
je me dis devrait y avoir deux couleurs
points en fait pour l'allemagne et pour
la france
ou est-ce que c'est au dessus de là je
comprends pas le c pour chaque heure il
ya huit mille cinq cent soixante heures
dans l'année chaque point représente une
heure et pour cette heure là j'ai
regardé la puissance réelle du parc
français en pourcentage de la puissance
installée et au même moment la puissance
réelle du parc allemand en pourcentage
de la puissance installée et si vous
aviez un effet qui et quand y'a pas
devant chez nous il y en a chez les
voisins en fait ces points il devrait
être organisée le long d'une ligne qui
va de la halle a en gros certains il ya
beaucoup de vent chez nous il y en a pas
chez eux quand il ya beaucoup de vent
chez eux y en a pas chez nous et
l'ensemble des deux est toujours à peu
près équilibré d'accord ça c'est un vrai
foisonnement c'est un vrai foisonnement
steria toujours du vent quelque part pas
au même endroit et évidemment tous les
points toute la ligne occupe tout
l'espace entre les deux c'est à dire
qu'il ya toutes les situations
intermédiaires vous avez un peu devant
chez les uns beaucoup de temps chez les
autres et c'est à ce moment
effectivement vous bâtissez les
interconnexions qui vont bien et vous
vous retrouvez avec l'ensemble du parc
franco allemand avec quelque chose qui
ont en gros est garanti là ce que vous
voyez c'est qu'au moment où il n'y a pas
de vent chez les uns il n'y a pas de
vent non plus chez les autres dont vous
pouvez pas vous dire où on n'y a pas
devant chez moi il ya de la puissance
garantie chez les voisins à ce moment là
il y en a pas chez les voisins je fais
l'avocat du diable vous le faites une
immense sur la france et l'allemagne
je les fais sur france espagne je les
fais sur toujours en bilatéral s'est
aussi fait sur espagne allemagne
mais est ce qu'on a fait parce qu'il
faut éviter de le faire sur une dizaine
de pays en même temps oui oui alors ça
ça a été fait aussi je vous épargne et
la courbe aujourd'hui mais je peux vous
l'envoyez ça vous donne le même résultat
l'ensemble des éoliennes européenne peut
descendre en dessous l'ensemble de 5 %
de la puissance installée en europe ont
besoin de ce ce graphique jeu jour
expliqué le choix critiqué le
foisonnement où je vais vous l'envoyez
c'est une donnée d'observation avec les
références mais je peux vous envoyer ça
voilà bah justement sa part et c'est
vrai aussi s'il y'avait foisonnement en
fait les points devrait être le long du
diagonale il devrait être dans ses dents
dans cette partie là du
il devrait pas sortir de cette partie là
du graphique ce que vous avez fait la
même chose avec éolien et solaire pour
voir si la ja foisonnement entre les
deux types d'énergie présentement entre
éolien et solaire parce que vous avez
plutôt plus d'éolien l'hiver est plutôt
plus de solaire l'été mais vous allez
quand même retrouvé des tendances
lourdes qui sont qui sont de cette
nature le solaire c'est pareil quand il
est quand il est minuit dr schrader il
est minuit partout en europe au même
moment ou presque
et quand il est midi les midis partout
en europe au même moment ou presque donc
c'est pas la production solaire et la
riche et tout le monde au même moment en
gros voilà bah voila je vous en avais
d'autres l'a donc ici vous avez entre la
france et l'espagne
donc ça c'est vous voyez france
allemagne france espagne mais qu'on est
encore dans le même genre de schéma
ici vous avez france lucas en bretagne
les points ont tendance à se concentrer
de parfum en bas à gauche
dans tous les cas de figure est ici vous
avez les deux régimes les plus décorés
les cons et en europe c'est-à-dire
espagne et allemagne
alors vous x là c'est déjà
significativement plus décoré les
cirques ya toute une plage ici tout une
plage là où en gros l'afrique la force
du vent en allemagne ne dépend pas de la
force du vent en espagne mais vous
n'êtes quand même pas organisé le long
d'une ligne qui irait de là vers la même
en prenant un régime de vents très au
nord et un régime de vents très au sud
donc l'idée que et puis par ailleurs
pour qu'on profite à plein du
foisonnement en europe
il faudrait quand même tirer quelques
centaines de giga watts de ligne
d'interconnexion qui aille de l'espagne
jusqu'en finlande pas complètement sûr
que c'est demain matin qu'on va y
arriver
or je rappelle que maintenant que la
france est engagée dans la neutralité
nous avons 40 ou 50 ans disent les
textes officiels pour réduire les gaz à
effet de serre à 0 40 à 50 ans en s'y
prenant bien c'est le temps qu'il faut
pour construire 10 % des capacités
d'interconnexion qu'il faut et 10% des
éoliennes qu'il faut pour arriver à
avoir quelque chose qui s'approche de la
consommation électrique l'actuel avec
juste ce genre de moyens pas
complètement sûr que on va y arriver et
je vais finir par une petite crique de
troie qui vous donne un ordre de
grandeur des différences
d'investissement entre un système alors
c'est caricatural mais moi j'aime bien
les ordres de grandeurs enfin les trucs
un peu caricaturaux parce que ça permet
d'approcher les règles de trois ça
permet d'approcher les ordres de
grandeur donc je prends un système que
j'appelle 100% nucléaire est un système
que j'appelle 100% éolien d'aucuns me
font remarquer qu'en france les barrages
concours à la flexibilité ce qui est
vrai mais aujourd'hui de nucléaire c'est
le faire aussi le nucléaire c'est faire
du suivi de charge
on sait avec le nucléaire baisser la
puissance d'un réacteur de 80% en 30
minutes dont le nucléaire français c'est
pas vrai pour toutes les centrales dans
le monde
le nucléaire française c'est faire de la
variation de charges ou à la même
vitesse une centrale à gaz habilité
alors ça dégrade un peu sa rentabilité
évidemment parce que du coup le facteur
de charge moyen va baisser
c'est absolument évident cela étant je
sais que sur le vétuste et du matériel
alors ça accélère aussi un peu la
vétusté du matériel absolument donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya des trucs qu'il faut
remplacer un peu plus souvent
il n'empêche que comme le nucléaire est
une énergie pilotable même un nucléaire
un peu plus cher parce qu'on lui fait
faire du suivi de charge
ça reste quand même moins cher ce que je
vais vous montrer que de l'éolien et du
solaire auquel il faut mettre du
stockage alors je commence le facteur de
charge d'un nucléaire qui fait du suivi
saisonniers parce que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui le nucléaire fait de la ce
village en france il est de l'ordre de
70% 80 les bonnes années l'éolien ça se
balade aux alentours de 20 à l'heure
avec toi tu sors ça sera peut-être 25 kg
shore est beaucoup plus cher on en
reparlera peut-être après donc
aujourd'hui en l'éolien terrestre on est
plutôt aux alentours de 20 en france
ce qui veut dire que la consommation
finale identique
je dois investir dans quatre fois plus
de puissance ou trois fois plus de
puissance si j'ai de l'éolien que si
j'ai du nucléaire puisque la puissance
moyenne j'ai envie de dire du dispositif
elle est trois fois plus faible
ensuite la durée de vie c'est pas la
même les éoliennes sont donnés pour 20
mettons que ce soit 30
la durée de vie du nucléaire est donné
pour 60
donc j'ai un facteur 2 qui se baladent
éventuellement 3 sais pas si vous savez
mais aux états unis
toutes les centrales ont été autorisés
pour 60 ans et un certain nombre
d'exploitants qui commencent à demander
les autorisations pour 80 alors c'est
pas le même régime qu'en france ça va
t'en mets donc là il faut sur une
période donnée
remettre au pot une deuxième fois si on
a de l'éolien donc ça veut dire que les
investissements il faut les renouveler
au bout de trente ans après il n'ya pas
d'adaptation réseau à faire si on reste
en nucléaire alors que si on met des
éoliennes partout il faut faire des
raccordements partout alors le coût de
ces raccordements n'est pas
proportionnelle à la puissance installée
il croît plus vite que la puissance
installée
parce que au début en fait on peut
adapter le réseau existe en effet deux
tuyaux condé grosses capacités donc les
branchements c'est juste les
branchements etc
mais à un moment quand on commence à si
on doit passer en tout éolien
aujourd'hui on a 100 gigawatts de
puissance sur le réseau on doit devoir
passer à une puissance installée qui va
se balader aux alentours de 4 ou 5 100
gigawatts
le réseau est pas dimensionné pour ça et
donc là il va falloir au gré des deux
réseaux et ça ça va évidemment on
enlevait des coûts donc moi j'ai dit
allez on rajoute 50 % après l'affairé
stocker alors là j'ai pris une hypothèse
qui est que je pompe l'eau du léman pour
noyer les vallées des alpes qui sont au
dessus je fais des grands barrages
réversible donc ça va faire beaucoup
plaisir à nos amis du génie civil
c'est ce qui coûte le moins cher si je
fais sur batterie c'est un ordre de
grandeur au dessus par rapport aux cours
multiplié par cinq à dix
par rapport à du stockage en barrage
réversible c'est beaucoup plus j'ai pas
compris votre 10% nucléaire c'est 10% du
coût d'une annoncé on doit stocker on a
quelques même avec un système 100%
nucléaire on doit quand même stocker un
peu parce que quand même des variations
de charge etc
donc il faut quand même mettre quelques
step alors qu on est au lien il va
falloir stockées en moyenne sur l'année
50 % de la production clair qu'il ya un
kilowatt heure sur deux qui sort d'une
éolienne qu'on va devoir stocker alors
c'est a deux conséquences
la première c'est que quand vous stockez
vous perdez 30 à 40% de ce que vous avez
stocker parce que il faut faire
transiter l'électricité dans le réseau
de l'éolienne jusqu'à la station de
pompage
là on perd 5% ensuite il faut pomper
l'eau de base en haut là vous perdez et
20 ou 25%
ensuite il faut l'arthur biner dans
l'autre sens là vous perdez 10% et après
il faut l'art transporté dans le réseau
dans l'autre sens donc par rapport à une
centrale pilotable si vous avez besoin
de stocker l'électricité vous allez
perdre 30 à 40% au passage ce qui veut
dire qu'il faut encore surdimensionné le
parc de 30 à 40% pour la partie qu'on va
devoir stocker faut rajouter ses
éoliennes là qui ne servent que à
produire l'électricité qui est perdue
pendant le stockage et puis vous devez
construire les stations de pompage
donc il faut construire les stations des
barrages réversible donc il faut
négocier avec les suisses complot du
léman et qu'on met ça dans des vallées
juste au-dessus négocier avec les
riverains qu'on va noyer et les vallées
juste au dessus quand on voit ce que
donne le barrage de sivens je n'ai même
pas me le coût des compagnies de crs là
dedans
par contre la puissance installée en
éolien vous coûte moins cher elle vous
coûte 1000 à 1500 euros du kilo watt
installé enfin offshore ça va vous
coûter un bras alors que le nucléaire
trop cher aujourd'hui coût 2 6 2 séries
optimisé coûtera 3 voilà mais quelque
part entre 3 et 5
donc là on gagne un facteur 2 à 4 en
faveur de l'éolien
il n'empêche que si vous faites la somme
des facteur multiplicatif et diviseur de
part et d'autre ça veut dire que dans la
meilleure cas de figure on arrive à
ça suffit plus à l'écran ce qui se passe
dans le meilleur cas de figure on arrive
un surplus de 5 ce qui se passe dans le
meilleur cas de figure un système éolien
plus stockage beaucoup de cinq fois plus
cher qu'un système nucléaire et dans le
pire des cas de figure il coûte 30 fois
plus cher on peut dire comment ils
demandent 30 fois plus d'investissements
donc là où la reconstitution à neuf du 5
fois plus d'investissements un peu plus
d'investissement donc là où la
reconstruction à neuf du système
nucléaire français même avec un
nucléaire cher va vous coûter 250
milliards d'euros dans le meilleur des
cas de figure un système éolien plus
stockage vous en coûte 1500 et dans le
pire des cas de figure il vous en coûte
10 mille milliards d'euros je suis pas
complètement sûr qu'on ait cet argent
alors si je fais le même si je fais les
mêmes règles d'autres non mais si je
fais mes mêmes règles de trois avec le
solaire jarriot même multiple à la fin
c'est même encore plus un peu plus
défavorable au solaire on est plutôt
entre 10 et 40 ans facteur multiplicatif
donc c'est une autre façon de dire que
contrairement il faut que je la tue
a lancé bon avec excusez moi donc ça va
disparaître
donc ça veut dire que le contrairement à
une idée qu on pense souvent dans
l'électricité le nucléaire est une
solution du pauvre est pas une solution
du riche et la raison pour laquelle on
accrédite l'idée que le nucléaire est
une solution du riche c'est parce qu'on
passe son temps à comparer des choux et
des carottes
c'est à dire une électricité pilotable
avec une électricité pas pilotable mais
si on re qu'on veut mais sur un pied
d'égalité les services rendus
à ce moment on se rend compte que
d'avoir des moyens comme l'éolien et le
solaire
ça amène à considérablement plus
d'investissements pour la même quantité
d'électricité produite à l'arrivée que
d'avoir du nucléaire d'où effectivement
la question qui est est-ce qu'on a tout
cet argent
ah pardon
et le coût environnemental voulait
évaluer le coût environnemental il ne
s'évalue pas d'abord en euros il s'est
valu une nuisance mardi dans ce jeu
propose de laisser ça pour le débat
après parce que là j'ai presque fini mon
je voulais finir par l'exemple de
l'allemagne
vous avez ici l'évolution des capacité
installée en éolien et en solaire en
allemagne dont vous voyez qu'ils étaient
à pas grand chose
dans les années 2000 ils sont
aujourd'hui au delà de 100 gigawatts de
puissance éolienne et solaire installée
donc si le raisonnement tenu en france
qui consiste à dire ça va chasser du
nucléaire et des capacités pilotable est
avérée on devrait voir les capacités
pilotable allemande diminué sur le même
dieu sur la même période
il devrait avoir aujourd'hui en combiné
moins de charbon et de nucléaire et de
gaz qui est diderot électrique qu'il
n'en avait en 2002 on est d'accord
alors voilà le résultat
le résultat c'est qu'ils en ont la même
quantité ça va pas bouger
c'est un peu monté un peu descendu un
peu remonté voilà bon ils ont moins de
nucléaire et plus de gaz par contre
alors ils n'ont pas diminué leur
consommation électrique vous avez ici la
consommation électrique allemande depuis
1995 j'ai pas les deux années les plus
récentes mais ça n'a pas beaucoup changé
d'accord vous voyez que c'est
globalement stable est ce que vous voyez
là c'est que les moyens pilotable donc
pétrole charbon gaz hydroélectricité
avait produit quasiment 500
térawattheures d'électricité en 2003 ces
mêmes moyens en ont produit moins de 400
en 2019 donc ce qui s'est passé en
allemagne c'est qu'ils ont gardé leurs
centrales pilotable ils ont un peu
changé la nature du parc un peu moins
nucléaires un peu plus de gaz et ils les
font moins tourner le facteur de charge
a baissé de plus de 20%
et comme la loi de kirchhoff est la même
en france et que la loi de conservation
de l'énergie est la même en france je
suis prêt à parier mon argent sur le
fait que si en france on développe
fortement l'éolien et le solaire
on ne va pas supprimer les capacités du
clae r on va moins s'en servir
c'est là dessus que je parie mon argent
et du coup on prend tous les
inconvénients tout un seul coup d'un
seul puisque 1
on dépense de l'argent dans des énergies
renouvelables qui ne changent pas les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
pays
2 on augmente les importations parce que
quand on passe d'un mégawatt heure
nucléaire 1 mégawatt heure solaire ou
éolien on passe de 1 euro d'importation
par mégawattheure à 20 à 30 euros
d'importation par mégawattheure donc ça
ça détruit de l'emploi macroéconomique
mansat ancré dans la filière mais c'est
en détruit globalement et enfin la
troisième chose qu'on fait c'est qu'on
augmente le risque nucléaire c'est quand
même ça quel est le truc est
particulièrement farce puisque vous
allez devoir garder un parc qui gagnera
moins d'argent enfin dont on va moins se
servir donc si le prix du mégawattheure
reste le même qui gagnera moins d'argent
et comme le signe clair est un système à
coûts fixes
si vous gardez un système à coût fixe
auquel vous donner moins d'argent
la probabilité pour que les risques
soient mieux gérées pas très élevé donc
pour moi
pour finir là-dessus en france ça n'a
strictement aucun intérêt sur aucun
aucun plan devient aucun plan de
développer les énergies renouvelables
électriques donc les seules bonnes
énergies renouvelables dont on doit
s'occuper en france et les énergies
renouvelables chaleur les énergies
renouvelables électriques n'ont
strictement aucun intérêt dans notre
pays sauf pour les antinucléaires et en
fait c'est la raison historique pour
laquelle on s'y est attaqué c'est parce
qu'au moment du grenelle dont je me
rappelle un tout petit peu notre ami
sarkozy avait dit on ne touchera pas au
nucléaire et donc les antinucléaires ont
dit attendons qu on va revenir par la
fenêtre
donc ils ont dit bah on va quand même
parler d'énergie renouvelable en soit si
vous voulez bas donc on va développer
l'éolien le solaire c'est à dire celles
qui sont concurrentes du nucléaire c'est
comme ça que l'histoire s'est écrite et
donc on a mis les milliards là dedans
c'est pas du tout pour une raison qui va
que ça s'est structuré comme ça à
l'époque c'est parce que ça a été poussé
à la roue par les antinucléaires et ça a
très bien marché je vais finir par un
petit quiz ici vous avez une courbe qui
vous donne la quantité de co2 émise par
kilowatts heure d'énergie primaire donc
la totalité du mix énergétique pas juste
l'électricité en allemagne et comme je
suis un peu taquin je vous ai max masqué
l'ap 6
quand vous voyez pas les années en
abscisses et donc c'est un truc que
j'aime bien montrer aux gens et je le
redis dites-moi de quand date le début
de l'énergie 22 est ce que quelqu'un
dans la salle est prêt à parier un café
une bouteille de vin un repas au
restaurant etc dit 'cela montre en main
mettant le doigt sur la courbe la
réponse est que sa date du début de la
flèche et que ces invisibles sur la
tendance dit autrement ce que les
allemands ont fait ne change pas la
tendance sur la décarbonation qui était
déjà à l'oeuvre lente mais qui était
déjà à l'oeuvre de leur mix énergétique
pardon primaire par contre cette blague
leur raccoon m coûtait alors il s'en
fiche parce qu'ils ont 10 % le solde
exportateur sur pib donc s'ils ont envie
de ce genre de plaisanterie ils peuvent
se le payer mais ça leur a coûté déjà
quelques centaines de milliards d'euros
investis c'est à dire que le coût total
des investissements qu'ils ont déjà dû
consentir
c'est quelques centaines de milliards
d'euros il est ils ont pas fini de les
payer mais c'est la valeur à neuf de la
totalité de ce qu'ils ont installés en
france pour la même quantité d'argent en
euros de 2017
en fait même pour la moitié moins la
gelée mais j'ai mis la reconstruction à
neuf parce que je suis sympa en deux
fois plus cher et bien regarder les
faits que le programme nucléaire a eu
sur le contenu carbone du mix
énergétique français
sur la totalité de l'énergie qu'on
utilise en france là vous voyez
clairement un effet discernable pourquoi
vous dites 300 milliards d'euros
investissent le coût du parc
non le coût historique ses 220 donc en
fait j'ai mis le coût de reconstruction
à neuf
parce que si on devait reconstituer
voulu comparer des choses comparables
donc là j'ai regardé ce que les
allemands avaient investi depuis le
début des années 2000 et je me dis si
nous on avait dû faire le parc nucléaire
depuis le début des années 2000 comme on
a rajouté l'état grec de sûreté dans
tous les sens ça ne coûterait pas sans
tiquer le coût historique ça nous
coûterait plutôt 250 le chiffre de cinq
mois j'ai eu un chef de la cour des
comptes qu'ils aient 75
c'est l'ordre de grandeur il ya d'autres
j'ai eu d'autres chiffre à 120 peu
importe l'ordre de grandeur c'est sans
quoi ses sens mais c'est pas les 1500 à
10000 dont j'ai parlé tout à fait
non le coût historique du parc nucléaire
français c'est 100 milliards d'euros et
le coût de reconstruction à neuf avec
les normes d'aujourd'hui et le coude le
père d'aujourd'hui et c'est même bien
fait en séries etc
je le mets plutôt à 200 250 300 enfin
dans cet ordre là ah oui j'avais ça ou
si j'avais l'exemple espagnol
ici vous avez l'exemple espagnol où vous
voyez que en même temps que les
espagnols depuis 1990 ont construit 25
gigawatts d'éolien ils ont construit 25
gigawatts de centrales à gaz
donc en fait comme il pouvait pas
compter sur l'éolien en puissance
pilotable ils ont construit en même
temps l'éolien et le back up pilotable
il aurait construit à la place 25
gigawatts de nucléaire
il aurait moins d'émissions de co2
aujourd'hui est moins d'importations gaz
à israël - d'éolien mais il y aurait
moins de co2 et en importations donc là
on voit bien c'est un deuxième exemple
après l'allemagne
donc l'allemagne et l'espagne me
conduisent à conclure de manière
extrêmement claire que augmenter les
énergies non pilotable dans un réseau
électrique ne permet pas de baisser de
manière significative la capacité
pilotable vous avez j'ai fait grandement
dépassé le temps qui vous et je suis
désolé mais là je suis un menteur je
dirais que la responsabilité n'incombe
pas ce que j'ai trouvé votre
présentation
c'est assez pertinentes à même le
rapporteur
oui ça marche partout donc en fait on se
rend bien compte que le sujet c'est
finalement la fin ce qu'on doit traiter
ces transports et bâtiments pour ce qui
est du carbone si on veut décarbonés
c'est très exactement de ça dont on doit
s'occuper temps et dans la partie
transports bâtiments les sujets alors
bâtiment c'est c'est la chaleur
principalement qui est carbonées et sur
les transports bas tout en gros donc la
question c'est quelles solutions vous
proposer pour le bâtiment et pour le
pour le transport pour aller vers une
décarbonation pour le bâtiment j'ai
quelques idées sur les réseaux de
chaleur renouvelable d'ailleurs votre
slide sur la part des nerfs en france
mettaient tout en bas tout en bas tout
en bas le solaire thermique et je
voudrais avoir votre avis sur le solaire
thermique et l'intérêt qu'il peut
présenter justement puisque ça remplace
une énergies carbonées
enfin qui est pour le chauffage par une
énergie pour le coup solaire qui est
complètement décarbonés et a priori dans
le coup est assez peu cher et voilà donc
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
énergie là alors d'abord la première
remarque que je vais faire alors ya
beaucoup de questions je vais essayer de
je vais commencer par la dernière il ya
il ya un sujet de conventions comptables
sur le solaire thermique
parce que dans le solaire thermique on a
coutume de mettre les chauffe eau
solaire et les chauffages intégralement
solaire mais vous pourriez mettre dedans
les vérandas orienté au sud
vous pourriez mettre dedans les baies
vitrées orientées au sud
enfin ce que je veux dire c'est que il
ya un sujet comptable sur le solaire
thermique qui est un sujet vraiment pas
simple parce que en toute bonne logique
si vous créez des ouvertures au sud dans
une dans un logement existant pour voir
faut être profiter de la chaleur leader
en rajoutons un auvent pour pas crever
tout l'été vous avez fait appel à du
solaire thermique c'est absolument pas
dans les statistiques
donc là les statistiques sur le solaire
thermique sont un tout petit peu
trompeuse c'est en fait juste et encore
une fois les chauffe-eau et le chauffage
au titre de lapointe ou du chauffage
central principal
c'est en général quelque chose qui est
aujourd'hui assez cher le solaire
thermique sert quand vous regardez le
coût du gaz quelles énergies carbonées
concurrentes faut vraiment avoir la foi
pour se faire remettre un solaire un
chauffe eau solaire thermique 1 alors
c'est parfait dans les dom si vous êtes
en guadeloupe ou en nouvelle calédonie
enfin dans les territoires d'outre-mer
d'une manière générale là vous avez vous
pouvez avoir intérêt à mettre un chauffe
eau solaire puisque ya du soleil en plus
plus souvent dans l'année mais en
métropole c'est quelque chose qui à mon
sens va pas devenir principal dans l'est
dans les marges de manoeuvre après si
j'essaye de répondre de questions alors
dans le bâtiment qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire
je vais vous répondre en ingénieurs et
ensuite je vais vous répondre en
législateur en ingénieur vous avez un
vous avez en gros un premier sujet qui
est il faut s'attaquer au parc existant
et non pas durcir les réglementations
sur le neuf le neuf aujourd'hui on
construit chaque année l'équivalent de
1% du parc de logements existants mais
c'est pas du renouvellement c'est de
l'accroissement le renouvellement réel
il est inférieur à un pour mille les
bâtiments ou les maisons qu'on détruit
pour les remplacer par du neuf c'est un
pour mille donc on ne peut pas compter
sur le renouvellement de l'existant par
du neuf dans lequel on aurait vidé
perdez des normes de performance dure
pour régler le problème
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut s'attaquer
directement à l'existant s'attaquer à
l'existant ça veut dire qu'il faut
sortir le gaz et le fioul de chauffage
c'est ça que ça veut dire c'est quoi les
modes concurrent alors vous avez deux
manières de faire ça la première c'est
vous pouvez en sortir tout en gardant du
gaz et du fioul en baissant tout
simplement la consommation à ce moment
vous isolez c'est le cas c'est le cas
classique où vous changez l'appareil de
chauffage
l'appareil de chauffage est un appareil
qui se change au moment où les cas ces
personnes de chance à chaudière pur
plaisir de changer sa chaudière une
chaudière se change quand elle est
vieille ou cassés
vous avez éventuellement des gens qui
changent l'appareil de chauffage quand
ils achètent un logement c'est un truc
était vieux et il considère que dieu et
qu'elle casse et donc il le change à ce
moment là mais il ya personne ne va se
lever le lundi matin en disant tiens je
vais changer la chaudière parce que la
nouvelle est moins n'existe pas ça on
prie compte le prix du fuel s'envolent
et que les gens stress du prix qui
seconde parce que la facture devient
enfin jir très lourdes pour les ménages
sur la question du chauffage à ce moment
ils font l'une des trois choses
suivantes
ou bien ils habitent à la campagne et il
se chauffe au bois ou bien ils habitent
avec une prise électrique et il met un
petit radiant onekey radiateur soufflant
ou bien il se pèle limmat un pull ou
deux ou trois mais oui c'est exactement
est en fait une bonne partie des
précaires énergétiques dans ce pays sont
chauffées au fioul
je le dit en passant donc ça c'est dans
le bâtiment
alors je vais finir ma réponse avec
comment est ce qu'on fait ça donc
maintenant j'ai ouvert la réponse du
législateur la réponse du législateur
c'est que la rentabilité intrinsèque des
économies d'énergie dans le bâtiment est
à horizon de temps beaucoup trop long
pour que les gens fassent ça pour des
raisons strictement économique donc la
seule raison pour laquelle ils vont
faire ça c'est si on les oblige donc moi
qui suis propriétaire
le gie slater dois me dire vous allez
dans les 30 ans qui viennent
isolez votre toit on vous demande pas si
ça vous plait ou si ça vous plaît pas
vous allez le faire
vous allez me dire si j'ai une chaudière
à fuel ce qui n'est pas le cas dans les
trois ans qui viennent
il sort interdit de remplacer la
chaudière à fuel par une chaudière à
fuel interdite alors qu'est-ce que je
peux faire à la place je peux remplacer
par une pompe à chaleur accessibles de
n'importe où tu as dès que j'ai un
branchement électrique je peux mettre
une pompe à chaleur
donc là je passe du fossile aux
renouvelables en plus c'est du
renouvelable bien près de chez moi parce
que c'est la chaleur de monsols où la
chaleur de montner donc celle là est
parfaitement locales alors que
l'éolienne ne l'est pas plus locale que
le barrage de serre ponçon
elle rentre dans le réseau et elle
alimente tout le réseau si l'éolien
c'était locales les allemands auraient
pas besoin de tirer des lignes
électriques 1 le fait qu'ils aient
besoin de tirer des lignes électriques
montre bien que c'est pas locales alors
que la chaleur la pompe à chaleur est
vraiment locale
je veux dire quand j'ai une pompe à
chaleur c'est ma chaleur à moi de mon
air à côté de mon sol à moi que je
transfère c'est pas celle du type qui
habite à 100 km
je peux la remplacer si je suis
raccordés au gaz et transitoirement par
un chauffage à gaz
c'est déjà mieux que le chauffage au
fuel mais idéalement il faudrait
directement remplacer sa part une
journée par une pompe à chaleur
alors maintenant je vais vous faire un
petit proposer un petit calcul vous
savez que dans ce pays on a décidé de se
lancer dans l'éolien offshore
l'éolien offshore aujourd'hui ses 25
milliards d'euros d'argent public
pierre vos impôts les miens et ce2 des
gens qui nous écoutent qui vont partir
dans le financement de ce dispositif qui
a encore moins d'intérêt que l'éolien
terrestre car s'il ya un truc qu'il faut
arrêter tout de suite c'est bien ça
c'est pas ce qui va se passer mais s'il
ya un truc qu'il faut arrêter tout de
suite c'est le 20 juin avec les 25
milliards d'euros en question vous avez
de quoi payer 6000 euros
6000 euros de prime de conversion du
chioula la pompe à chaleur eau 4
millions de ménages français qui sont
chauffées au fioul qui sont souvent des
ruraux souvent précaires et souvent des
gilet jaune soit dit en passant
6000 euros de prime de conversion
dit autrement là vous auriez une
subvention aux énergies renouvelables
avec laquelle moi je vote des quatre
mains qu'on augmente mon taux
d'imposition pour payer ça je veux bien
mais qu'on me prélève un centime d'impôt
pour aller payer l'éolien offshore ton
truc de shadocks aucun intérêt par quoi
d'autre est ce que vous pouvez remplacer
par de l'isolation donc là je le dis il
faut obliger puisqu'il n'ya pas de
rentabilité économique évidente faut
obliger alors il ya quelques dispositifs
d'obligations qui sont très simple par
exemple tous les ravalements de
bâtiments qui n'ont pas de caractère de
caractère architectural up isolation par
l'extérieur obligatoire parce que le
coût principal d'un ravalement c'est
d'échafauder une fois que vous avez
échafaudé le coup de l'isolant ces 10%
du coût de l'opération alors ça par
contre c'est rentable les de payer 10 %
de plus pour les économies d'énergie que
ça va générer donc le collège de votre
gamin là du béton des années 70 qui est
le lait comme pas possible bien le jour
on fait un ravalement par l'extérieur
crack isolation par l'extérieur terminé
et c'est obligatoire si on vous demande
pas si ça vous plait ou si ça vous plait
pas comme ça
donc c'est comme ça qu'il faut s'y
prendre dans le bâtiment donc il faut
décarbonés l'appareil de chauffage est
embarqué l'isolation dans des gestes que
les gens devront faire de toute façon
c'est sale et de bonne manière de
traiter le bâtiment et durcir les
obligations sur le neuf de strictement
aucun intérêt aucun ça c'est pareil
c'est de l'argent jeté par les fenêtres
en ce qui concerne les transports
alors les transports vous avez deux
grandes catégories qui sont très
différentes vous avez la mobilité du
quotidien et la mobilité longue distance
la mobilité donc distance est
essentiellement une mobilité de loisirs
vous partez en vacances vous allez voir
votre vieille belle-mère enfin quand
vous arrivez à convaincre votre mari d'y
aller vous et c'est donc vous vous
faites des choses qui n'ont qui sont de
l'ordre entre guillemets du luxe sur des
choses qui sont sympathiques à faire
mais qui sont pas essentiels alors que
dans la mobilité du quotidien vous avez
des choses essentielles qui sont d'aller
au travail ce que vous imaginez pas une
seconde que vous n'allez pas vous
déplacer pour économiser du pétrole
si ça vous évite d'aller au travail
juste pas envisageable et vous avez dans
le même ordre de grandeur le même ordre
d'idée l'école enfin l'enseignement les
courses
enfin voilà vous avez un certain nombre
de choses de cette nature cessé de
mobilité qui se traitent de manière très
différente parce que vous pouvez
substituer une partie de la mobilité
locale part du vélo c'est même pas la
peine d'imaginer substituer de la
mobilité longue distance part du vélo
donc c'est les manières de les marges de
manoeuvre dépendent énormément de ce
type de mobilité alors dans la courte
distance les marges de manoeuvre au sens
large s'appelle rester dans le pétrole
mais mutualisé s'appelle les transports
en commun et notamment des bus ça
s'appelle rester dans le collectif
mais faire du collectif lourd donc je
ferrais mais le ferret souvent c'est
long c'est pas rentable
donc en fait le le collectif léger
c'est-à-dire le bus c'est vraiment le
truc j'ai envie de dire qui est souvent
la réponse pertinente
vous avez le covoiturage qui est
toujours du collectif au pétrole ou
doublés ou triplés dans la mobilité du
quotidien le
le remplissage des voitures et vous avez
évidemment le changement de chaîne de
traction donc le passage à l'électricité
etc
quand vous faites un petit calcul
d'ordre de grandeur vous vous rendez
compte que il vaut beaucoup mieux dans
un premier temps investir dans les modes
dans les transports en commun légers aux
frais de la collectivité 1
c'est à dire les bus le covoiturage et
dans une mesure réglementaire dont je
vous parlais juste après qu'ils aient la
consommation des voitures et dans un
deuxième temps seulement électrifié tout
ça parce que vous aurez besoin de moins
d'électricité et vous aurez surtout
besoin de moins de puissance appelée
parce que le gros problème quand vous
faites les calculs d'avoir une
électrification totale du parc c'est pas
tellement la quantité totale
d'électricité que ça va vous consommez
sur l'année c'est les appels de
puissance que ça va vous engendrez aux
pics de charge
c'est à dire le 1er août quand tout le
monde va vouloir surcharger la veille en
charge rapide pour partir en vacances
voilà vous faites péter réseau j'ai pas
dans la courte distance le nom là
j'étais dans l'électrification distance
oui excusez moi absolument alors
changement c'était une incidence pas
pour c'était une incidente je disais
juste si on électrifie toutes les
voitures après les gens vont aussi
vouloir s'en servir pour la longue
distance par dont j'aurais dû préciser
ça et à ce moment ci on électrifie le
parc de voitures aux conditions
actuelles de puissance des voitures
vous risquez d'avoir l'impossibilité
physique de se recharger un certain
nombre de moments dans l'année
parce qu'il ya juste pas assez si j'en
reviens donc la courte distance vous
avez un dernier point qui est essentiel
c'est de d'accélérer la vitesse de
baisse accélérée par dont la vitesse à
laquelle on baisse la consommation des
véhicules neufs vendus sur le marché
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui il ya un outil
européen qui dit presque la même chose
qui sont les émissions de co2 des
voitures alors il faut que le co2 qui
sort d'une voiture c'est rien d'autre
que le pétrole qui y entrent donc plus
vous durcissent et les émissions de co2
en conditions réelles et pas en
condition des normes que personne de
rencontres dans la vraie vie
plus vous allez baissé de fait la
consommation de pétrole de la voiture
hélas qu'il faudrait idéalement c'est
que en 2030 n'est plus une voiture
vendue qui dépasse 2 litres aux 100 en
consommation réelle et 6 a conduit les
gens qui avaient des espaces et des
modèles plus gros que ça à ne plus avoir
d'espoir tant pis d'après g il restera
des voitures pour la mobilité du
quotidien dans lesquelles vous n'avez
pas besoin de rentrer tous les enfants
la grand-mère et le chien une politique
nataliste autres recommandations alors
la politique nataliste on va en parler
après c'est un vrai sujet non non c'est
un vrai sujet jeu il n'existe pas de
propre il n'existe pas de solution au
fait de tenir dans une boîte fini qui
passe par le fait que la population soit
en expansion a défini sa marche pas donc
on a un vrai débat à voir qui
aujourd'hui est un débat très difficile
douloureux sensible
j'ai envie de dire c'est encore plus un
bâton merdeux que le nucléaire mais on a
un vrai débat à voir aujourd'hui qui est
est-ce que c'est pertinent dans le monde
fini qui est le nôtre de continuer à
avoir une politique nataliste et ma
réponse est on prêt sur ceux ci
les questions difficiles comme il nous
reste 28 minutes
c'est une question difficile un jeu j'en
ai j'en ai parfaitement conscience alors
juste pour finir là-dessus et donc le
donc le sur la mobilité longue distance
là pour le coup vous avez raccourcir les
distances en voiture partir en vacances
d'ailleurs un peu moins loin vous pouvez
mixer les moyens de déplacement si vous
achetez un petit véhicule pour la
mobilité du quotidien et que vous avez
beaucoup de gens à déplacer au moment
des vacances et au moment des vacances
vous achetez trois places de train ça
vous reviendra de toute façon beaucoup
moins cher que d'acheter un gros
véhicule qui est vide l'essentiel de
l'année sauf le conducteur de toute
façon si les gens étaient rationnel dans
leur achat de voiture ils achèteraient
une toute petite voiture et au moment où
ils ont besoin de se déplacer à saint
qu'ils enverraient trois personnes par
le train c'est ça qui ferait j'irai les
chercher en train etc
on peut faire le calcul c'est l'équation
économique c'est très vraiment y'a pas
photo le donc sur la longue distance je
dirais les grands enjeux qui alors après
je vais venir aux manières là dedans
mais les grands enjeux c'est remplacer
l'avion par le train raccourcir les
distances
voilà en gros il ya moins de solution
facile c'est évident alors les énergies
renouvelables adam et bien objectivement
le mix énergétique là dedans tout ce qui
consiste à remplacer du pétrole et du
gaz part de l'électricité nucléaire moi
j'aime bien donc remplacé du chauffage
au fioul et au gaz par des pompes à
chaleur
j'aime bien remplacer des véhicules
thermiques par des véhicules électriques
quand l'électricité est fait avec deux
avec du bas carbone et que la
fabrication de la batterie parce que
c'est de la métallurgie la fabrication
de la batterie est faite avec du bas
carbone
j'aime bien aussi dans le chauffage il a
une énergie renouvelable qu'on peut
utiliser alors avec parcimonie parce
qu'il s'agit pas de couper toutes les
forêts françaises mais c'est la biomasse
donc le chauffage au bois
ça reste quelque chose qui est paillot
les biocarburants viennent en conflit
avec les surfaces agricoles et si dans
le même temps on veut rendre
l'agriculture française un peu plus
extensive
parce qu'on veut utiliser moins
d'intrants moins de phytosanitaires
moins d'engrais moins de ceux-ci - de
cela à iso production on a besoin de
plus de surface
pas de moins donc là on a un petit sujet
si vous à la fois d intensifier
l'agriculture si je puis me permettre
et avoir plus de surface pour des
cultures énergétiques
là on a un conflit c'est assez dur
il ya une énergie renouvelable pas
inintéressante qui est le biogaz est en
fait l'usagé premier du biogaz devraient
évidemment pas être de faire de
l'électricité qui est concurrente de
l'électricité nucléaire donc qui a comme
l'éolien et le solaire aucun intérêt
pour moi mais de faire d'eux des
carburants pour les engins agricoles
parce qu'en fait les les premiers
intéressés à s'abstraire du pétrole
c'est ce qui aujourd'hui participe à la
chaîne alimentaire
c'est donc la mèche et le machinisme
agricole qui pour moi devrait être le
premier bénéficiaire du biogaz on sait
faire des gros moteurs à gaz devait des
fabricants qui aujourd'hui ça va faire
ça c'est les mêmes que les moteurs de
bus soit dit en passant
s'il en reste derrière on peut faire un
peu de gaz de réseau pour faire la
cuisine
mais faire du biogaz pour faire de
l'électricité au biogaz
pour moi c'est un truc a pas de sens
beaucoup mieux faire du nucléaire et
faire du bio gaz pour se chauffer sa
raisonnablement peu de sens il vaut
beaucoup mieux passer à la pompe à
chaleur
voilà en gros donc si je résume les
énergies renouvelables qui sont vraiment
pertinente pour moi c'est la pompe à
chaleur et de manière raisonnée
ce qui vient de la biomasse plus dans
les bâtiments le solaire thermique dont
j'ai parlé au début c'est à dire les
ouvertures au sud les vérandas etc enfin
ce qui permet d'avoir du chauffage
solaire direct l'hydrogène n'est pas une
énergie primaire cirque on n'en trouve
pas dans la nature c'est un vecteur
comme l'électricité donc il faut le
faire avec autre chose
aujourd'hui donc l'hydrogène ça n'est
qu'un moyen de stockage
enfin de conversion et de stockage d'une
autre énergie l'hydrogène aujourd'hui on
sait très bien en faire des grandes
quantités parce qu'il ya deux grandes
utilisation industrielle de l'hydrogène
la première c'est la désulfuration des
carburants
donc dans toutes les raffineries des
pays occidentaux vous avez des unités de
production d'hydrogène qui sont repérés
soit par air liquide soit enfin une mise
en place son père l'équipe soit par ses
concurrents mais c'est de la production
d'hydrogène fossiles c'est de
l'hydrogène qu'on va chercher dans du
méthane styrène du gaz naturel est en
fait le méthane ch4 donc un atome de
carbone et quatre atomes d'hydrogène est
en fait vous jouer aux lego à l'envers
ses avocats c'est le truc vous récupérez
le carbone d'un côté en fait vous allez
le récupérer sous forme oxydée co2 sa
part dans l'atmosphère et l'hydrogène de
l'autre côté et vous faites ça en
chauffant et le chauffage est fait avec
une autre partie du gaz naturel donc ça
et mais plein de co2 et la deuxième se
production d'hydrogène importante dans
les pays occidentaux c'est la chimie de
la bagnac donc c'est pareil on prend
l'hydrogène on l'associé avec l'azoté de
l'air ont fait de l'ammoniac et
l'ammoniac c'est le début de la chimie
des engrais notamment
donc on sait très bien faire de
l'hydrogène en grande quantité avec du
gaz ça crache plein de co2 le défi de
l'hydrogène si on veut s'en servir comme
vecteur à ce moment c'est de le faire
avec des énergies sans carbone
qu'est ce que vous avez comme énergies
sans carbone d énergie électrique
essentiellement donc ça veut dire que
l'hydrogène pourrait être intéressant
doit être plus intéressant que la chaîne
électricité
puisque le début de l'histoire de
l'hydrogène cetc de l'électricité donc
il ya des gens qui vous disent on va
faire pleins d'éoliennes du coup on va à
l'électrolysé de l'eau quand il ya du
vent et qu'on sait pas quoi faire et ça
nous fera de l'hydrogène qu'on va
transporter et utiliser et moi je vous
dis ça c'est physiquement possible ça
reste beaucoup moins intéressant que
d'avoir des centrales nucléaires
pilotable et du coup vous avez pas
besoin des éoliennes et vous n'avez pas
besoin de faire de l'hydrogène pour
stocker l'énergie quand il ya du vent et
que vous en avez pas besoin l'ensemble
et aux liens plus stockage d'hydrogène
est une variante de ce que je vous ai
présenté tout à l'heure simplement vous
faites le stockage sous forme
d'hydrogène au lieu de le faire sous
forme de barrages réversible puisque
vous parlez du stockage tout votre
argumentation sur pilotable non
pilotable repose sur l'absence de
stockage oui certains des personnes
certaines personnes que nous avons
auditionné nous ont dit mais le stockage
ça va venir dans quelques années donc
très bien avant d'investir dans une
industrie nucléaire qui nous engage pour
50 ans il serait plus intéressant de
alors génie dans les quelques années on
a vraiment à rien d'investir du tout
parce qu'on va faire le grand carénage
je suis pas sûr qu'on va décider d'une
énorme quantité de réacteurs neuf qu'on
va construire
donc si c'est rentable dans quelques
années vous le redis très bien on se
revoit dans quelques années à ce moment
là puisque stockage coûte rien on met le
stockage à votre charge
et quand l'éolien stocker vos 60 euros
le mégawattheure on vous en achète ce
que ça vaut rien vous allez être
d'accord ensuite je suis pas
complètement sûr qu'ils vont vous dire
oui vous laisse méditer ensuite vous
avez quelque chose qui m'étonne c'est
que nous avons auditionné pas mal de
monde
vous êtes le premier mot à dire à faire
il ya gérer toutes sortes de scénarios
de position et vous été le premier à
nous d'écrire je dirais une manière
aussi claire
catégorique même je dirais l'inanité de
la stratégie qui aujourd'hui poursuivi
pourtant on a des agences de l'état dont
c'est la spécialité qui ont été
auditionnées et qui nous ont plutôt dire
conforté dans l'idée qu'on allait dans
la bonne direction
donc moi je m'interroge pourquoi est-ce
que la cré et les personnes en question
c'était qui quand nous avons vu monsieur
car un qu il a créée et nous avons vu
rte
le président brottes donc la question
que j'ai envie de vous poser c'est
comment ça se fait que notamment créé
des jeux c'est bon alors la dgec l aile
et le je dirais le le pilote de la
locomotive des énergies renouvelables
donc ça peut se comprendre mais ce que
je ne comprends pas c'est pourquoi deux
autres organismes comme rte la craie qui
ont une vision assez transversale je
dirais du sujet nous est pas un
aboutissement au même diagnostic
rte dix ans plus tôt on sait faire on va
pouvoir gérer le foisonnement
l'intermittence etc et la créer une ou
dix ans par la voix du président car un
co alors on ne fait pas des énergies
renouvelables pour le pôle objectif co2
est en réalité il faut diversifier le
nucléaire en ses fans je ne crois pas la
mienne nucléaire comment expliquez-vous
ce hiatus entre votre réflexion
académique et la réflexion il me
traitait alors d'abord en plusieurs
éléments de réponse d'abord l'idée que
toute dernière diversification et
pertinente n'est pas une idée à laquelle
je souscris si on me coupe une de mes
jambes et qu'on la remplace par une
jambe de bois
j'ai diversifié mes appuis je ne suis
pas sûr que ma situation globale se soit
améliorée donc on peut très bien se
diversifier en remplaçant ce qu'on a pas
moins bien et à ce moment on a perdu on
n'a pas gagné
or c'est exactement ce que je viens de
soutenir pendant une heure et demie
c'est qu'on s'apprête à remplacer ce
qu'ont à part moins bien donc oui on
diversifie
mais à l'arrivée on s'en porte pas mieux
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que vous me posez une question
difficile parce que je n'ai le choix
qu'entre comment dire ne prendre aucun
risque en 10 au joker je répondrai pas
donc les gens ont dit vous disent qu'ils
veulent ou bien contredire ces éminentes
personnes sur la base de ce que je crois
en savoir alors d'abord vous n'êtes pas
sans ignorer qu'elle était le précédent
employeur de monsieur brottes
j'avoue il était monsieur brandt à
mourir tu es ma connaissance il était
député oui il m'a dit il était dans
cette maison bon il était même président
de la commission des affaires
économiques qui était en pole en
fonction au moment où on a voté la loi
de transition énergétique donc que
monsieur brottes vous explique
aujourd'hui que l'objectif de l'article
1 de la loi de transition n'est plus
pertinent demande peut-être à monsieur
brottes
comment dire enfin je vois qu est-ce qu
il ay gagner rien ce qui là ils perdent
je comprends donc je vois là de même
s'il le pense je suis pas sûr qu'il faut
le dire la deuxième chose c'est que rte
quand vous lisez les documents de rte
c'est comme les documents de l'ademe
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est les
petites lignes puis comme les contrats
d'assurance vous savez mais c'est
justement celle que vous allez pas lire
donc vous allez lire les gros titres de
la presse et vous êtes bien placé pour
savoir que les gros titres de la presse
c'est ce qu'a dans le communiqué de
presse donc il suffit de bien faire le
communiqué de presse une presse qui vous
dit des choses sympathiques
la question qu'il faut poser à mon avis
à ces gens là donc je ne sais pas si
vous la leur posez c'est est-ce que vous
pariez jusqu'au dernier euro de vos
économies avoue que ça ça peut marcher
moi j'aime bien qu'on pose ce genre de
question j'ai pas si vous l'avez poser
et à ce moment c'est cette réponse là
qui m'intéressent qu'un système puisse
marcher si on a une quantité infinie de
milliards devant nous comme bien sûr
qu'on peut faire un système avec 50%
nucléaire est l'un des hauts-lieux
excusez moi les petites lignes de rte
ce que vous avez
ouvert un sujet on n'a pas vu les
petites lignes de rte y'a quoi dans les
petites lignes ouvertes à lorsque j dans
les petites l'insee les hypothèses et
les conditions aux limites
par exemple la part des importations il
faut aller regarder de très près puisque
je vous ai montré tout à l'heure que si
les pays suivent la même évolution que
la nôtre c'est pas sûr qu'ils aient de
l'électricité à exporter quand nous on
en a besoin
bon je sais pas si ce bouclage la a été
fait ou pas d'accord c'est ça les
petites lignes il faut aller vérifier
que ce truc là a été fait un autre
exemple c'est dans le scénario alors rte
je connais pas très bien mais dans le
scénario 60 et 100 % aux nerfs de
l'ademe
vous avez dans les hypothèses le fait
que 60 % de la consommation du pays et
effaçable donc si vous vous demandez
gentiment vous faites pas votre lessive
vous débranchez votre frigo vous prenez
pas les scanner vous prenez pas le
l'ascenseur vous prenez pas le train
vous êtes industriel vous arrêter les
machines etc paraît beaucoup quand même
et ça sans investissement à la charge du
consommateur
quelques doutes en tout cas moi je
parlerais pas mon argent là dessus donc
vous avez comme ça des conditions aux
limites dans le résultat qui sont des
hypothèses qui sont des trucs qui sont
postuler mais c'est pas parce qu'un truc
est une hypothèse que c'est
vraisemblable vous pouvez postuler une
hypothèse qui est totalement
invraisemblable
moi je peux très bien imaginer ce que je
ferais si j'étais capable de voler et je
peux écrire un bouquin de 200 pages là
dessus mais si je veut transposer ça
dans le monde réel vous êtes en droit
challenge et l'hypothèse de départ donc
là c'est exactement ça vous avez de
temps en temps ce qu'il faut c'est un
long et fastidieux travail de revue des
hypothèses ou de revues des conditions
aux limites
la presse n'a évidemment absolument pas
le temps de faire ça
absolument pas donc les voilà donc c'est
encore une fois moi j'ai pas lu toute la
production de tous ces gens là j'ai bien
regardé le scénario 100 % à venir de
l'ademe sur lui a jeûné bien regarder
pour moi il n'a aucune espèce de
vraisemblance enfin en fait il est auto
logique c'est à dire que ils vous disent
en entrée je suppose que ça vaut pas
cher les nerfs puis je suppose que j'ai
pas de coûts de réseau significatif que
le consommateur peut s'ajuster aux
fluctuations de la production et donc en
sortie pour 500 investissements et donc
en sortie ça vaut pas cher
bah oui c'était pas très difficile de
dire des choses comme ça je ne parle pas
que monsieur karakoé fait de longues
études d'électricité sur le plan
physique crois pas que ce soit son
parcours
donc monsieur caraco il va vous dire ce
qu'il sait lui mais mais là moi je vous
ai parlé de physique je vous ai pas la
partie économique découle de la partie
physique je vous ai pas parlé d'eux
et je vous ai surtout pas parler de
politique je n'ai pas dit parce qu'on a
déclaré qu'on allait le faire on va le
faire je vous ai montré quelques
évolutions historiques celles de
l'allemagne et de l'espagne qui
n'accrédite absolument pas les
hypothèses considérées comme
vraisemblable que vous pouvez trouver
dans certains discours public français
et notamment le discours public qui
consiste à dire qu'on va supprimer de la
capacité nucléaire en augmentant les
deux nerfs électrique ce que j'ai trouvé
dans l'évolution observable des pays qui
nous entourent
c'est l'exact inverse et à chaque fois
que je le fais remarquer à des gens que
j'ai en face de moi ils me disent pas il
me donne pas d'argumentaire construit
sur pourquoi est ce que nous on serait
plus intelligent que les autres je les
ai pas donc il existe peut-être mais
pour le moment je les peins alors après
un dernier point physiquement et ça ça
explique peut-être la réponse de grottes
physiquement passer à 50% de nucléaire
en mettant des éoliennes et des panneaux
solaires partout ça ne pose pas de
problème ça ne pose pas de problème ça
ne pose pas de problèmes techniques
parce que vous allez avoir toujours vos
centrales nucléaires dont vous vous
servirez moins souvent donc vous aurez
pas diminuer le nombre de centrales vous
aurez juste dix mouvements ou
marginalement vous allez peut-être
fermer une ou deux mais bon vous allez
rajouter des éoliennes et les panneaux
solaires à ce niveau-là de rage ou
d'éoliennes et de panneaux solaires le
réseau vous êtes capable de le faire
monter en puissance pour que ça soit
capable d'encaisser le truc donc ça
techniquement sa flotte
maintenant la question c'est qu'est ce
que ça nous apporte et ma réponse est
rien
donc je voudrais vous poser la question
de la tendance d'augmentation ou pas des
consommations électriques à l'avenir
parce que donc si on considère
qu'aujourd'hui on a une consommation
telle qu'elle est qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'aller chercher autre chose si on
conserve le le nucléaire tel qu'on l'a
et qu'éventuellement on fait 20 confesse
ce grand carénage et c'est donc on
investit ce qu'il faut pour ça on garde
la structuration existantes
est ce que dans les années proches du
coup on sera obligé d'aller quand même
compléter ou est-ce qu'on peut s'en
sortir autrement et si on obligeait de
compléter est-ce que la compétitivité
des nouveaux
nucléaire seront ou pas compétitif par
rapport aux nerfs ça c'est ma première
question si vous voulez augmenter la
puissance garantie vous serez obligés
d'augmenter la puissance pilotable donc
même si vous mettez des éoliennes vous
serez aussi obligé de mettre autre chose
avec
c'est ce que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure avec les espagnols donc c'est
pas parce que la consommation électrique
augmente que on peut s'en sortir juste
avec des éoliennes en plus parce que si
elle augmente avec un besoin garantie de
puissance par exemple les gens ont
besoin d'électricité au moment où le
chargeur voiture parce qu'on augmente la
consommation d'électricité au moment via
via l'électrification du transport vous
avez besoin de puissance garantie même
chose pour les pompes à chaleur vous
avez besoin de puissance garantie parce
que c'est au moment où la pompe se met
en fonctionnement que l'électricité doit
être disponible et donc ça c'est clair
merci cc oui c'est logique
par ailleurs du coup l'augmentation du
volume d'électricité consommée c'est
quoi les tendances et est ce que parce
que ils avaient parié sur une
augmentation de la consommation
d'énergie finalement elle a pas eu lieu
est ce que là du coup de ce que ça a été
stable finalement par rapport à ce qui
avait été prévu et là est ce qu'on peut
considérer que ça ne va plus être stable
ou est ce au contraire on peut
considérer que ça se restera stable
alors il il faudrait une heure
supplémentaire pour vous dire pourquoi
je sais ça que je crois mais hors
électrification des usages je pense que
ça ne va pas augmenter et que ça devrait
même légèrement baissé
et alors or électrification des usages
oui alors pourquoi est-ce que je pense
ça parce que je pense que toutes choses
égales par ailleurs
d'ici à ce que vous mourriez l'économie
française devrait se contracter alors
pourquoi est-ce que je pense ça parce
que l'économie n'est qu'un vaste système
de transformation une transformation
l'économie je transforme des pierres de
carrière en béton je transforme des
fibres de coton en vêtements je
transforme des marchandises qu'ils
étaient ici en marchandises là s'appelle
du transport il sauf que la
transformation par définition en
physique c'est l'énergie en fait
l'énergie avant d'être une un sujet
passionnant de discussion ici c'est une
grandeur physique
c'est justement pour ça que c'est soumis
à des lois qui ne dépendent pas de nous
et en fait la marque de la
transformation en physique on quantifie
la transformation en physique par
l'énergie c'est à ça que ça sert du coup
un système économique est ce qui a fait
part dont l'augmentation de la
productivité du travail dans les pays
occidentaux c'est pas qu'on s'est mis à
avoir 45 bras et 253 jambes comme shiva
c'est qu'on s'est adjoint des machines
qui travaillent en plus de nous ou plus
exactement à notre place donc en fait la
consommation d'énergie c'est juste
d'augmenter le parc de machines
augmenter la consommation d'énergie
ce que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure
c'est que l'énergie finale dominante
consommée en france c'est le pétrole
parce que c'est les transports et les
transports c'est un maillon
intermédiaire indispensable de toute la
machine économique
or il se trouve que l'offre de pétrole
disponible pour les européens
d'ici à ce que vous ayez mon âge et
d'ici à ce que vous mourriez va évoluer
comme ça donc en tendance le pib
exactement donc on aura moins de pib et
à partir du moment où on a moins de pib
là vous avez des boucles de rétroaction
qui rentre en compte les gens ont du
coup au moins de moyens de s'acheter des
appareils et du coup une partie des
appareils qui consomment de
l'électricité on a moins les moyens de
se les offrir à la désindustrialisation
elle est très très lié oui elle est
irréversible au sens du flux
énergétiques entre 1974 et 2007 j'avais
regardé ça le produit industriel
français a doublé bocchia pas du tout
une désindustrialisation en france après
les chocs pétroliers produits
industriels doublé ont fait moins de
chaussettes et plus des russes mais
c'est
alors ça ça doublé et il se trouve que
l'europe a passé son maximum
d'approvisionnement énergétique en 2006
enfin ce même si en secondaire premier
été en échec pétroliers et depuis 2006
la production industrielle européenne à
tendance globalement à décliner
exactement en miroir de la quantité
d'énergie qui rentre en europe alors une
autre raison pour laquelle c'est
dangereux d'abandonner le nucléaire en
pensant qu'on va le remplacer par des
énergies renouvelables qui ne seront pas
je voulais montrer tout à l'heure au
niveau auquel on les attend parce que
l'école la quantité de capitaux à mettre
sur la table est beaucoup trop
importante
c'est qu'en fait vous allez lâcher la
proie pour l'ombre donc vous allez vous
priver d'un approvisionnement
énergétique donc de machines en
fonctionnement donc vous allez contracté
le pib encore plus vite
donc ce que la contrepartie essentiel de
se tromper d'objectif
dans l'arbitrage nucléaire nrc que vous
allez accroître la contraction
économique
alors si c'est ça l'objectif j'ai rien à
dire ce qu'on peut dire c'est ça
l'objectif pas tout ce qui me gêne et
jusqu'à maintenant mon propos essentiel
c'était de vous dire la seule chose qui
me gêne dans tous ces débats c'est de
vouloir le beurre et l'argent du beurre
ou bien d'attribuer à une forme
d'énergie dont je rappelle que c'est une
grandeur physique des caractéristiques
physiques qu'elle n'a pas voilà ça ça me
gêne
après si les gens disent moi j'ai bien
compris qu'on allait contracté
l'économie avec ce qu'on est en train de
faire ça me gêne pas ça pas très bien
parce que vous savez que derrière
derrière le modèle idéologique de des
aînés a des nerfs est aussi un modèle
politique est plutôt un modèle de la
décroissance un pas pour tout le monde
donc pas pour tout le monde
mais est-ce que vous tout à l'heure vous
avez parlé de l'essence pour l'essentiel
des promoteurs des urnes hier que je
rencontre ce n'est pas du tout le cas
nommé juste mais l'idée à la base de
fantasio nerfs électrique égale à base
de ce qui était défavorable au nucléaire
notamment toute la partie écologie oui
ça on est la corée la décroissance
vous avez près de la boîte finit donc
vous or l'un des arguments justement de
l'idéologie
écologiste c'est de dire le monde est
finie il a des limites et c'est ce qui
explique d'ailleurs qu'il faut donc
moins consommer et donc décroître etc
semblent un peu perturbant que
finalement vous aider vous soyez en
adhésion avec cette idée de bois de fini
puisque j'ai un nom ceux qui combattent
cette vision notamment le malthusianisme
des mots démographique explique qu' on
est on est dans un univers infinie dans
un monde fini
c'est à dire que le végétal notamment
est infini qu'ils se touchent génère se
reproduit se développe et que donc par
conséquent si on estime que demain les
algues permettront de faire du
biocarburant n'y a pas de problème parce
qu'il aura toujours la ressource
comment est ce que vous vous positionnez
alors la première chose c'est que on a
tout acteur parler du stockage en dix
ans demain il y aura du stockage ans qui
aura pas de problème et je pense que si
on a une gestion prudente de cette
affaire là on compte sur les forces dont
on est sûr en se disant s'il ya une
bonne surprise je saurai toujours en
faire quelque chose
moi qui suis aussi un petit chef
d'entreprise c'est comme ça que j'ai
envie de résonner dans mon entreprise
c'est à dire de prendre un pari a besoin
j'ai dépensé tout l'argent que j'ai
parce que demain j'étais de gagner au
loto
j'ai vite je préfère me dire je compte
sur ce dont je suis sûr je vais essayer
d'avoir un peu mieux et puis si j'ai un
peu mieux tant mieux j'en profiterais
mais si j'ai pas mieux au moins j'ai pas
pris de risques inconsidérés
donc moi j'ai envie de dire faisons avec
les moyens du bord de toute façon ça ne
pose pas grandir on sait quoi faire avec
les moyens du bord j'ai pas besoin
d'avoir des progrès majeurs sur le
stockage pour remplacer le fioul par des
pompes à chaleur donc je vois pas
pourquoi on le ferait pas j'ai pas
besoin d'avoir des moyens de stockage
massif pour remplacer une partie du gaz
par des pompes à chaleur dont je vois
pas pourquoi on ne ferait pas
l'approvisionnement gazier je vous ai
montré thaler la consommation de gaz de
la france j'ai vu qu'elle a commencé à
décliner en 2005 2005 c'est le moment où
la mer du nord a passé son pic de
production 60% du gaz européen en venait
à ce moment là aujourd'hui c'est encore
la norvège va passer son pic de
production c'est le dernier grand pays
producteur de la mer du nord qui a passé
son pic elle va passer son pic de
production dans les années qui viennent
à ce moment ça va dégringoler encore
plus vite et donc
il n'y aura pas de plus en plus de gaz
en europe il va y avoir de moins en
moins donc déjà les gens aussi qui vous
disiez le gaz c'est l'énergie de la
transition
voir parce que c'est pas sûr qu'on en
aura plus en plus ce que ce que là alors
je suis moi aussi un décroissante east
pas au sens où ça me fait envie mais au
sens où je dis je vois pas comment on va
y échapper ce qui est un peu différent
donc pour moi il faut gérer à l'économie
parce que ce qu'on va avoir comme moyen
ça va être à l'économie et c'est
justement pour ça que je suis partisan
du nucléaire parce que ce que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure c'est que c'est un
moyen à l'économie quand vous regardez
système complet donc je pense que le
nucléaire est un amortisseur de la
décroissance c'est comme ça que je vois
le je vois le système est donc si on
s'en prive
eh bien on se font tondre seul en plus
mal
or justement ça ma dernière question
aujourd'hui quand vous voyez le
traditionnel rendez vous avez tout à
l'heure vous avez laissé passer vous
avez dit autre chose à faire ce serait
stoppée l'éolien offshore
si ça ne sera pas fait donc je vois si
vous avez une forme de pessimisme dans
vos propos mais imaginons que cette
commission denquête puisse effectivement
avoir un impact et modifier le cours de
l'histoire
ou pas quels sont les prêts vous les
trois risques principaux si on continue
sur cette lancée même si nous échouons
ou si nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur le
diagnostic ou pour vous que sont les
risques majeurs qui pèsent sur
l'économie française
alors je vais plutôt dire qui pèsent sur
la société française parce que je vais
pas réduire la france à son école
voulait absolument me censurer complot
non là lorsque le risque majeur c'est de
perdre une course contre la montre
la question du changement climatique et
la question de la déplétion des énergies
fossiles cd course contre la montre sur
une fois que vous avez passé le pic de
production en mer du nord
année après année ça diminue si vous
n'êtes pas capable de vous organiser
pour vous contenter de ce qu'ils
continuent de sortir
eh bien vous prenez des claques en ce
qui concerne le changement climatique
c'est pareil
le changement climatique est un
processus cumulatif c'est à dire que
année après année le gaz les gaz à effet
de serre s'accumulent dans l'atmosphère
je rappelle quand même qu'il faut
attendre plus de dix mille ans pour
épurer un surplus de co2 qu'on met dans
l'atmosphère dix mille ans d'accord donc
c'est ça concerne le monde dans son
ensemble donc les déchets nucléaires à
côté de ça c'est de la petite bière
enfin dix mille ans de déstabilisation
mondiale irréversible donc le autre
chose juste dans les dents les éléments
scientifiques il faut avoir en tête il
ya de la science assez récente
qui a dit que si on dépasse les 2 degrés
et qu'on a de très bonnes chances de
dépasser
on met en route de manière irréversible
la déstabilisation de la calotte
antarctique de l'ouest ce à quoi on
ajoute le groenland qu'à toute façon
commencer à fondre et on est parti pour
avoir à une échelle de temps qu'on
pensait être quelques siècles il ya pas
si longtemps et aujourd'hui on dit on ne
s'est pas avancé récent qui hurle ça
pourrait plus rapide que ça on met en
route
allez plus de 9 mètres d'eau dans
l'océan mondial plus de 9 mètres dos
c'est facile vous rendez compte
bangkok sous l'eau shanghai sous l'eau
dunkerque sous l'eau miami sous l'eau
une partie de new york sous l'eau par
dont quelques siècles pensait-on
maintenant on ne sait pas bon non mais
voilà donc vous pourriez vous réfugier
sur le mont ventoux
il suffit de bien choisir les électeurs
que vous les laisser sous l'eau mais
donc le sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte de ce avec quoi on est en train
de jouer donc cette course contre la
montre je considère qu'il faut faire feu
de tout bois sans mauvais jeu de mots
pour être capable de la gagner et là
dedans quand je met en balance le
nucléaire avec les risques du changement
climatique ou de la déstabilisation
sociale qui va venir d'une économie qui
se contractera trop vite alors que les
gens comprennent pas d'où ça sort il a
juste pas photo pour moi je sais on
n'est pas du tout en train de parler des
mêmes eshet au projet un peu la trouille
pour mes gosses avec ce qui vient des
combustibles fossiles et du changement
climatique déchets nucléaires je m'en
fout comme de l'an 40 pour non pas un
sujet qui m'empêche de dormir
pardon de ce langage un peu cru mais je
veux dire c'est justement donc le voir
revenir à ce que je disais le risque
majeur c'est de perdre une course contre
la montre alors combien on a mis dans
cette course contre la montre
aujourd'hui qu'on est en train de perdre
vous connaissez les chiffres comme moi
éolien offshore inclus on est à 150
milliards le compteur s'est arrêté à 150
à fin 2010 8 derrière les 121 de la cour
des compte plus les 25 de l'offshore
donc en ordre de grandeur
non parce que dans des logiques de la
cour des comptes on prenait en compte le
fort à 40 milliards en fait à 3
milliards d'euros
alors mettons science actualisé pas plus
les 37 qu'on veut mettre dans le cas de
la ppe n'ont donc on est quand même à
140 bonbons donc non mais dont on jure
devant le rayon entre 100 et 150 150 peu
importe avec cet argent là j'aurais pu
payer une pompe à chaleur
non non non la totalité de la pompe à 10
à 15 millions de ménages français
donc là je sortais la totalité du fioul
et les deux tiers du gaz
donc là j'avais gagné une partie de ma
course contre la montre j'avais évité
15% des importations de pétrole
donc selon les années de 3,6 milliards
d'euros ou même un voire même 9
j'avais évité la moitié de les
importations de gaz donc macroéconomique
mans là je crée de l'emploi puisque je
vis des importations donc je récupère du
pib j'avais évité du co2 donc
l'arbitrage qu'on est en train de faire
nous prive d'une chance qui est celle
d'arriver à faire ça alors qu'est ce qui
se passe si on le fait pas et bien comme
le gaz et le pétrole qui rentre en
europe ont continué à décliner
eh bien vous aurez de moins en moins
d'énergie de chauffage de toute façon
corps a été remplacé par rien vous aurez
de moins en moins de transport de toutes
façons corps ont été remplacés pas rien
vous aurez la tentation de recourir aux
énergies fossiles
là où il y en a pour construire des
dispositifs de production électrique
quand vous verrez que les renouvelables
ça marche pas donc nous on n'est pas
trop concerné parce qu'on importe tout
mais les allemands complaints de charbon
peuvent très bien rajouter des unités à
charbon les polonais aussi et
non
oui la france a quelque chose à y gagner
parce que la france importe en tout de
toute façon même si vous croyez pas au
changement climatique
à partir du moment où vous savez que la
zone va être de plus en plus contraintes
sur les énergies fossiles
vous avez intérêt à vous en débarrasser
le plus vite possible de toute façon est
alors le combat contre le co2 on ne
gagnera jamais tous
non on ne gagnera jamais tout seul mais
je vais mettre de codicilles important
d'abord la france n'est pas encore pour
le moment un pays totalement inaudible
en europe sauf qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
notre combat
aujourd'hui notre combat hors d'europe
c'est le déficit budgétaire moi ça
m'intéresse moins que le changement
climatique j'ai aussi un peu moins peur
pour mes enfants à cause du déficit
budgétaire si les gens de ma génération
doivent être tondu parce que l'on
rembourse pas la dette basso it on sera
tendu et puis voilà quoi c'est pas c'est
moins grave que le changement climatique
c'est grave mais moins grave que le
changement climatique donc le donc on
peut très bien en europe décidé que
cette histoire de lutte contre les
émissions de co2 et de diminution de la
dépendance de l'économie aux énergies
fossiles c'est la colonne vertébrale du
renouveau européen moi je suis très
favorable à cette idée parce que d'abord
un projet saas incarne autour d'un objet
sas incarne pas autour si vous allez
parler aux gens qui vous entourent
prochaine fois que vous passez dans un
seul service vous demandez aux gens qui
font qu'ils préparent la nourriture de
l'autre côté on verra ce que ça vous
excite conte et 3% de déficit budgétaire
vous dire d'un projet pour la france
samedi pas trop ce que c'est oui donc
donc je pense que c'est un projet qui
serait intéressant par ailleurs les gens
fonctionnent par mimétisme
c'est comme ça qu'on élève nos enfants
donc l'idée qu'on dise nous on va
commencer à faire des choses
intelligentes et personne ne va nous
imiter j'y crois pas il reste dans mon
univers professionnel on a fait un truc
qui est très très loin d'être suffisant
mais qui est un bon début qui est
l'article 73 de la loi de transition sur
l'empreinte carbone etc
il ya plein de pays qui sont en train de
nous imiter donc l'idée que si nous on
fait des trucs intelligents on va rester
seul dans notre coin
je n'y crois pas une seconde pas une
seconde très bien et bien écoutez
monsieur jean cau ici ce sera le mot de
la fin je vous remercie pour cette très
riche présentation
voilà et nous allons immédiatement faire
le transfert pour passer la troisième
audition nos journées